What's up, everybody?
Happy Fourth of July weekend,
and what better way to celebrate than with today's guest.
A young man born in the country of Mali,
who immigrated from West Africa
to the States when he was a teen,
then becomes a professional soccer player,
and now a U.S. citizen, and the very first black person
to ever run 3,000 miles across America.
A truly extraordinary feat, eclipsed, perhaps,
only by his incredibly inspirational positive vibe,
and another noteworthy accomplishment,
a four-plus year run streak.
In other words, this guy has run every single day
without missing a single day for 1500-plus days in a row.
His name is Hellah Sidibe.
He goes by hellahgood on Instagram and YouTube.
He is an endless font of positivity and inspiration.
His enthusiasm for life, for running,
and human potential is infectious.
And he's here today.
This conversation is a sheer delight,
so hit that "Subscribe" button.
And please welcome Hellah Sidibe.
I can't believe you're here, man.
I can't believe I'm here.
I can't stop smiling.
My cheeks are really,
(Rich laughing)
it's starting to hurt now. (laughs)
You're smiling all the time anyway.
Yeah.
You know?
Uh-uh.
It's an absolute delight to meet you.
Thank you for coming out to do this.
I'm so excited to talk to you.
Thank you for having me.
It's a thrill to meet you.
Congratulations on-
Thank you.
On the run and everything.
Yes.
Super exciting, man.
I'm grateful to be here
and in your presence as well, so thank you so much.
Did you get your run in today already?
Of course.
How many days now?
Today is day 1,500 consecutive days actually, yeah.
(Gasps) Today's 1500 on the dot!
1500, yeah, 1500, yes, yeah.
Wow!
No matter the circumstances,
I gotta get out there and get it done.
Another reason to celebrate.
Yes.
Another milestone,
the first 1500.
Exactly, yeah.
That's unbelievable, man.
Thank you.
So, so many things to talk about.
Of course, we're gonna get into the transcontinental run,
and all of that.
Just by way of background, I first became aware of you
because of our mutual friend, Robbie Balenger.
Robbie Balenger.
I didn't know anything about you,
and when he dropped in on your run,
I think you guys were going through the Navajo Nation
at the time.
Yeah, we were in,
he surprised me in Guymon, New Mexico in the morning.
Right.
Yeah, we were in New Mexico-
He just showed up out of the blue.
He just showed up.
You didn't know.
I had no idea.
I was like, wait, is this, am I going crazy,
'cause I got out of the RV
(Rich laughs)
and I'm like, "Wait, it's Robbie?"
It was the best surprise.
It was awesome to see him.
How many days did he run with you through there?
He was with me for that weekend, Saturday and Sunday.
So, he did all Saturday, all Sunday,
and left that night on Sunday
when I finished the day Sunday.
So, that was my first exposure to what you were doing.
Yeah. (laughs)
And I was like, "Who, is this guy?"
Like how has he so positive?
This guy is smiling
Thank you.
Through all this suffering.
I was like I need to know more.
I started following you.
And I was like all in on this adventure and this journey.
And then when you were completing the run that final day,
I tuned into Robbie's Instagram
and everybody's congregated outside your house
in New Jersey.
Uh-huh, that was cool.
I'm like, "Oh, this is gonna be awesome."
And then I was like, "Wait a minute, is that Casey?"
Yeah, Casey showed up.
When I went out of the house, I was like, "Whoa.
I know he surprised you too.
I thought Casey was in LA.
Yeah.
That's what I thought.
Well, I knew he was on the east coast.
I actually had texted him earlier that day
about getting introduced to his brother
because I wanted to meet his brother and just have him
on the podcast.
Yeah, I got to see.
Yeah, which is cool, I just saw that.
So, we were going back and forth on that.
And he said something like,
"I'm driving on the freeway right now,
but I'll get back to you."
And then suddenly, I see him in front of your house.
I texted him again.
I was like, "Wait, you know Hellah?"
(Hellah laughs)
Like all these worlds are converging.
I didn't know you guys knew each other.
It's insane.
But I guess you had done some stuff at 368.
Yeah, so, Casey had his people reach out to me.
I was actually on a flight from San Francisco.
And when I first went to the YouTube space
to do a YouTube-a-week event,
where YouTube invited us to help us create
and it's called YouTube Black.
And we get there.
And then Casey was one of the people I'm always like, "Wow."
And I see him in the YouTube hall of fame.
It's fiction.
Like how do I be Casey?
And one of the worker was like whispering to me and says,
"Hellah, I'm not supposed to probably tell you this,
but I think Casey has a new space or something,
but that's your best bet."
And then I just left it at that.
So, I'm flying back from San Francisco.
And then my girlfriend at the time, now fiancée,
sent me a screenshot of the email saying,
"Oh, we're inviting you to the first Thanksgiving party ever
hosted by Casey."
And I started...
I screamed on the flight.
And then I looked around quick
'cause I was like, don't scream
(Rich laughs)
'cause they're gonna kick you out of the flight
if they think you're crazy.
And that was the first event I was invited to.
And I met Casey.
And then when he saw me, he said, "I saw your video.
You ran every day for a year."
I said, "Yeah, this is really incredible.
We gotta get a run in."
So, that's how the relationship started.
That's very cool.
Yeah.
And it was so great that you made that vlog
of that whole experience.
That was really cool.
When you guys were crossing the finish line,
I don't know who in your congregation
was doing the Instagram live,
but I was watching that Instagram live.
And then the sound cut out.
I'm sure you know that, right?
Yeah, everybody was talking about the sound, yeah.
Everyone was like, "No sound. No sound. No sound."
And I was like, "What is happening?"
Because I knew you were giving a speech.
I couldn't hear it.
And I knew something momentous was happening
'cause people were going crazy.
So, I called Robbie.
Oh, that's good. (laughs)
And I was like, "What is going on?
Are you gonna tell what's happening?"
He's like, "Oh, it's insane.
He just proposed."
Yeah.
It was really cool.
Yeah, it was my best friend that was driving the RV
and Garrett Jones.
I said, "Go live.
You gotta go live right now my Instagram to get this."
So, my hellagood family members
can watch what's happening right now.
Cool.
Uh-huh.
Well, let's walk it back a little bit.
I wanna hear the whole story, man.
Yeah.
So, let's start at the beginning,
growing up in West Africa.
Yeah, I grew up in West Africa, Mali.
So, Mali is one of the poorest countries in the world.
People make less than a dollar a day.
But I was very fortunate to be in a family
where they kinda hide everything from you.
I had no idea as a child that I was living in poverty.
So, that's the best part.
And you just live your life.
The only thing they ask from you is you go to school,
you take care of your schoolwork,
and we play soccer all day.
So, living there,
you kinda really see how much happiness is happening there
because no one really is like kind of burdening
on what's happening, the poverty.
The sense of nationalism,
how we look out for each other and take care of each other,
really help and mold and shape you,
who you are as a human being.
So, after leaving there, you look back,
and you can be nothing but grateful
for whatever lifestyle you're living after that.
So, I grew up there.
And 1995, my dad was in the US in Illinois
to do his PhD at Northern Illinois University.
'97, my mother came to join him
to do her master's at the time.
My youngest brother was four.
I was seven.
My sister was nine.
And we were kinda old enough to be left behind.
So, we were left behind with my mom's sister.
Unfortunately, half of the year into the school,
she passed away.
So, there's no one to look out for us.
So, they got us visa to come and join them
for like the rest of their school year,
which was '98 to '99.
So, I was in the US, '98 to '99
and we flew back home and that was it.
So, I picked up English a little bit.
I was in elementary-
You were like seven at that point, right?
Yeah, at Jefferson Elementary School I went to Illinois.
And then after that, we're just there,
just continue with schooling.
And fast forward to 2002, my mom came back to the US
to do Fulbright scholarship to do her PhD.
And then we saw schooling in Mali
was really like up and down.
There's always strikes.
Teachers are not teaching.
So, it was best to get us here.
So, I came here, so at the end of eighth grade
and I started freshman year of high school here in the US.
What was it like after doing a year in the US
when you were super young and then going back?
I had actually the biggest problem too,
because language barrier, I'm starting to learn English.
So, when I went back now mixed stuff with French,
because we speak French as an official language in Mali.
And then bombing, I would mix everything up.
So, when I was actually at school,
I was having a tough time learning
compared to the rest of my siblings.
So, that was tough for me.
But having that experience was just like
the biggest culture shock for me.
I remember everything vividly.
Yeah.
Yeah, at that age.
Well, to be going back and forth like that,
probably gives you an added layer of perspective
on the differences.
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
Yes.
But when you ultimately went back to begin high school,
when you came to the United States, was that in Illinois?
Is that where you kind of went to high school?
Yeah, still the same town, DeKalb, Illinois.
Same town, yeah.
Right, right, right.
And your parents are super accomplished.
Yeah.
I mean, they're highly educated.
I know.
How are they doing now?
A lot of freshers.
Yeah, both of them are retired now.
And my mom was over 20-plus years as an English professor.
Dad also.
So, my dad has a PhD in the US, France, and England,
and my mom has a PhD here and she has two masters.
So, my older sister has a master.
Wow.
So, there's a lot of education.
You're the broke wierdo.
I literally I'm the weirdo of all.
(Rich laughs)
And younger brother, who's a mechanical engineer.
And so, everybody, I was the only one actually
that graduated high school at the normal age, at age 18,
where they were all graduating at 16.
Wow.
Yeah.
So, I was the athlete.
That's interesting.
Yeah. (laughs)
Cutting your own unique path.
Exactly, yeah. Yeah.
Which under that kind of pressure,
I'm sure hasn't been easy.
It wasn't easy at all.
Yeah.
For sure.
But soccer was the thing.
Soccer was always my dream.
If you ask the 16-year-old Hellah,
"Where would you be by age 25,"
I had a goal in my mind to be playing in England
for Chelsea FC.
Chelsea was my team and soccer was all I wanted.
And I realized toward the end of high school,
that I can go to school for free.
So, I started taking it serious,
to a point where like my school grades was falling apart.
And I came to the realization,
"Hellah, you can be as good as you want in soccer,
but if you don't take care of your grades,
you're not gonna go to college."
So, I started working well on both of it
and I was able to get a scholarship
to go to University of Massachusetts.
Right.
And you played there.
Yeah.
And ultimately took a stab at being a pro, right.
Yes.
Which had its kind of ups and downs.
Yeah.
That was a interesting story to me because for me,
even to think that I could play professionally,
just all happened by,
in terms of a kind of a event that I didn't kinda plan
for it to happen the way it did.
So, I was playing for this team called Boston Victory.
So, I said, PDL team, Premier Development
or Professional Development League,
where you can play at a high level
and keep your college eligibility.
So, we're playing against a team called Worcester Hydra
in Worcester, Massachusetts.
And I was Boston Victory.
And there's a kid that was playing there,
I'll never forget his name, Charlie Rug.
Charlie played at Boston College.
He was like ACC player of the year.
Scored 20-something goals a season.
So, my coach said, "Hey, Hellah,
I'm gonna have you play left back
because I know you have pace.
You gotta keep up with this kid because he's really fast."
So, I shut him down.
Didn't go anywhere.
I was up and down the flank.
And had him even focused on defending me versus attacking.
And if there's images of us,
like literally I was glued to him.
I didn't give him any space.
But Sporting Kansas City had a scout
sent to go watch that game, specifically for that kid.
And after that, my little brother acting agent
emailed some MLS teams and said,
"I have a brother playing division one."
So, Sporting Kansas City emailed me
and said that, "We came to watch a game.
And in fact, we wanted to look at someone else,
but we're interested in you."
Yeah, forget that other guy.
What's going on with Hellah?
"We're curious if you can play left midfield."
And I was like, in fact, that is my position.
I was only playing defense that day
so I can shut down the player from BC.
And that's when the interest of professional started for me.
And I was like, wow, I can play in the MLS.
That's incredible.
Wow.
Yeah.
So, what happened in that?
'Cause there were some like fits and starts.
I mean, I've read a little bit about this,
but it sounds like you were positioned to do really well,
but there were visa problems
and other kinds of things behind the scenes
that really kind of prevented the trajectory
going in the way that you wanted it to.
Yes, so back then they had the super draft
and the supplemented draft.
So, super draft was like the first top rounds,
and supplemented draft was the later rounds.
And I was,
the Sporting Kansas City emailed me and said that,
"We're looking at you in the supplementary draft."
So, which is like the later round.
And then they said our concern is visa issues.
So, the visa was the biggest problem.
And to a point where they said that, "We can find someone
as talented as you, or even not as talented as you,
but we don't have to worry about visa issues
so we can develop them to be where you're at."
So, that was the factor.
So, I got invited to this combine.
And Sporting Kansas City was there.
So many other MLS teams were there.
And I was with this coach who was a head coach
for Kitsap Pumas in Seattle,
which is part of the Seattle Sounders.
And he realized the visa issue
and he wanted a Sporting Kansas City coaches
and said, "Let me have Hellah for one year.
And I'll even help him with the areas
that you want him to improve.
Hopefully within that year, we can sort out the visa stuff."
And I signed my first professional contract in Seattle
playing with the Seattle Sounders affiliate.
So, I was basically their foreign in team.
We played against MLS teams.
And actually, my first start, first game
was against the Vancouver Whitecaps in Canada.
And I got to get my first tested.
I missed my graduation for that, which was cool.
But the visa issue was the biggest for me.
Yeah, it's interesting, because foreign nationals,
there has to be a lot of foreign nationals
who are kind of entering into the MLS system, right?
Yeah.
So, the immigration thing has to be something
that they're dealing with all the time.
Yeah.
And there's a Roster cap.
I don't know if it changed until this point,
but in the national Roster space.
So, out of like 22 to 26 players,
only eight players can be foreign.
And I have this message sent to me
by a coach in Sporting Kansas City.
He said, "Hellah, listen, I'm sorry,
but we would rather have someone from Europe
and that can sell jerseys pick up that spot
versus someone new coming in."
Wow.
So, basically, it-
It's like commercial reasons.
It becomes even more of that.
So, if you're a foreign national,
you have to be extra time-
Yeah, a big time.
Yeah.
Yeah, big time, and you get that spot.
So, that got played out.
I mean, how long were you part of that organization?
For the team in Seattle?
Yeah.
Just the season.
And right away, actually,
I had my assistant coach from college,
had a roommate in college
when he was playing in college at Tampa University,
Ray Finkle, who was an agent recruiting players
to go to Europe.
So, I had a chance to go play in Germany
with the Bundesliga 2,
which had some US national team players.
So, nothing was guaranteed.
Playing time wasn't guaranteed.
But to be there for a certain amount of time was guaranteed.
And I had to make my way up.
So, I flew from Seattle, went to Boston
and I went to the German embassy for my visa.
They shut it.
They said immediately,
"We're concerned you're not a US citizen.
Let's say you get to Germany, the season's over,
your contract is done, are you gonna go back home?
You're immigration threat in a way.
You're probably not gonna go back to Africa.
We don't want you to be an immigration issue in Germany."
So, they shut that down.
Wow.
Yeah, I was sad about that because I was really-
That has nothing to do with how good you are
as a soccer player.
No, it's something that's out of your control.
And a friend of mine that got connected,
well, he's a friend, we were connected.
We were going together.
He was a US citizen.
A goalkeeper actually from California.
He went there and I saw him living his dream
playing in Europe, which is cool.
But seeing that, I was like, "Ah, man,
I could've almost been there, but visa also."
So, you're a super positive guy.
Yeah.
That must have left you
with a little bit of a bitter taste
or something like that, right?
A little bit, yeah.
It got tough for me at that point.
And you get to a point
where you're like you start pointing fingers.
And some of the excuses I was making back then
were very valid.
I got shut down to play in the youth national team
in the US.
I remember I was invited to go to Sarasota
to play with a youth national team
when I was playing with the Chicago Fire, Chicago Magic
back in Illinois.
And they said, "You gotta go tell your mom
to get you your passport."
I thought it was that easy.
I went, "Mom, mom, give me my US passport."
She's like, "Hellah, it's not that easy."
So, all that start coming back into your mind
and you feel like you have zero control.
So, you get to a point where everything really bothers you.
So, and then I was always a happy, exciting person.
And that was really bothering me.
At the time, I didn't know I was depressed,
but if you were to ask me,
then I would say to people, "Well, I'm just frustrated."
So, there are things that never bothered me
would start bothering me.
And then now I look back,
I think I was really depressed back then.
And I just got to the realization,
which is, with a run that made me feel like that
to a point where I was like,
"Hellah, what can you control now?
What are you in control of in your life?"
'Cause those things are not.
So, that's when I started taking responsibility and say,
"Go do what you can do, and focus on that.
Put your energy there, not the areas you can't control."
And what was that?
I mean, when faced with the prospect
of your professional career not panning out, what's next?
I literally told myself one day,
"I'm tired of making excuses.
I gotta do something
that I can hold myself accountable for."
And then fitness comes to your mind.
You're an athlete.
And I said, "Hellah, whenever you tell yourself
you're gonna hit the gym for a week straight,
you go two, three days, you tap out."
And I said, "What is something that I'm afraid of?"
Running heavy immediately.
So, playing division one, even at the pro level running,
I was always afraid of it.
At UMass Amherst, the track team used to look at us,
"Are you guys the UMass track?
You guys were on so much."
Our coach was very proud of me.
May he rest in peace.
Sam Koch was very proud to say,
"You guys are gonna be the fittest team in the country."
So, anything you do, any mistake on the line,
we want to play top teams, the day before, he makes us run.
So, I was fitness test.
I was afraid of it.
I couldn't sleep the night before.
I could play 90 minutes.
No problem, because with soccer, you're heading 50/50 ball.
You're attacking, you're defending.
It's not just solely focused on running.
So I told him, I asked myself, "What are you afraid of?"
And running hit me.
And I said, "You know what?
I'm gonna go face my fear of running.
Let me just go 10 minutes a day for two weeks
and zero pressure."
It doesn't matter if 10 minutes
mean you don't even get to a mile.
That's okay.
So, I told myself that.
Within the first week, I fell in love with it immediately.
So, I ran to Alexa Torres, my fiancee.
I was like, "I think I can do this for the rest of my life,
but I don't wanna get ahead of myself.
Let me do this every day for a year."
So, that's how the whole run streak started.
Right.
So, it was really born out of this frustration
and a little bit of confusion
about what the next chapter was gonna look like.
Yes. Exactly. Exactly.
That's how it all started.
It's also interesting that your frame on running
is through the lens of punishment.
Yeah. Uh-huh. (laughs)
When you are on a sports team, it's not run-specific.
It's like being told to run
is what happens when you get in trouble?
Literally. Yeah.
It's like the stick.
If it has two minutes of mine, I get so stressed
the night before a fitness test.
They can see it.
They're like, "Hellah, are you okay?"
I'm like, "I just can't stop thinking about that big test
tomorrow morning." (laughs)
(Rich laughs)
Or like the corporate says,
"Well, you gotta run two miles under 12 minutes."
And if you don't make those times,
you gotta be in breakfast club,
which is extra fitness before the actual practice.
And the actual practice has his own fitness in it.
So, it really got me all confused and scared
and petrified ultimately.
But you're super fit.
So, when you started this streak,
I think you said you went out and ran 10 minutes
or something like that.
Yeah, it was 10 minutes a day.
That was the goal.
You're certainly capable of doing more than that.
Yeah, way capable.
And that 10 minutes didn't even last.
It was just the first week I ended up finding myself
running even four miles.
But the whole point of that idea of saying 10 minutes a day
was to have zero pressure.
'Cause I know if I were to tell myself, "Hellah,
you gotta run at least five miles a day,"
that's something at that point in my mentality
and physical ability for running,
wasn't something I was kind of capable of maintaining,
but I knew something attainable to do 10 minutes.
So, it was a mental thing.
So, that made me feel like,
okay, you're doing this with non-pressure enjoying.
Spring was in the air, it was May 15th of 2017.
So, it was just a perfect amount of time
for me to be out there.
So, that's why I said 10 minutes.
Streaks are so interesting psychologically, right?
Yeah.
I think it's really powerful
to talk about setting a really low bar
if you're contemplating something like that
and making it doable.
Yeah. Yes.
So that you can actually learn to enjoy it
before it becomes too challenging.
Exactly.
Where you're gonna pull the rip cord
before you've even gotten out of the gate.
Yeah.
But once you develop a little bit of momentum,
it becomes like this self-perpetuating thing, right?
Yes, I agree.
I don't know why that is.
It's that thing, and I've said it many times before,
when you're going to the gym consistently,
it's just easier to go.
Or if you're running every day,
it's easier to get out and run.
And get it done.
But if you break that cycle, if you interrupt it,
even once-
Oh, man. (laughs)
And you just create all kinds of anxiety
and strain on yourself.
Everything.
That makes it so difficult.
Yeah, the starting over thinking and all that.
So, it's very true.
Exactly how you said it.
Right.
So when you first began this,
was the idea of a streak even in your mind,
or you were just like, "I'm gonna go out and run
'cause I want to be able to have some control over myself."
It wasn't even as streak.
It was just two weeks that I needed to do.
And the thing is, to my knowledge,
I didn't know what streaking actually was for running.
I didn't even know it was a thing in the running community.
I was so new to the running community.
But just for the record,
we're not talking about running naked. (laughs)
(laughs) Yes, we're not really.
We're talking about running consecutively so well.
Consecutively, yes.
Yeah, that's a good point.
That's about it. (laughs)
(Rich laughs)
Yeah, so, I was very ignorant to it and didn't know.
And that was really good.
I'm glad I didn't know about it
because also that would have been, "Oh, people streak?"
That's another pressure that I didn't need.
So, I didn't even know.
And that it was just to get out there.
And I just knew I wanted to do it every day now for a year.
Is there a whole world of people
who do these streaks out there and document them?
I discovered...
Not document.
I think humbly we became hellagood,
like my YouTube channel and with my fiancee,
'cause it's a team,
we became basically the first people
to really put it on the platform of running every day
and running every day for a year, 365 days.
And then now everybody that won't do it, started doing it.
Or everybody that were actually been doing it,
started documenting it and push it out.
And which I'm so happy about
because I actually am happier for more people
who are doing the streak compared to me,
because a lot of questions comes, "Oh, he's the lucky one.
How is he able to do it?
But when I see someone else, then I'm like,
"See, it's not just me.
Look at this person did it.
That person did it."
So-
When you made your 365 day, your one-year streak video,
most of that video was clips of other people out running
in different parts of the world.
Exactly.
Because I realized how much running brought us together.
And we started building a community.
And I wanted to show that to people
and talk about my story of how running every day
changed my life and how people became a part of it.
So, to me, it's all about the people.
I think people make the experience.
You could do a lot of stuff by yourself,
but without the people, I feel like it's not the same.
Right. Right.
Well, at first it becomes this journey of self-discovery
and an exploration of your own personal existential.
Exactly.
But at some point, it becomes rote
and it has to become about something else
in order to maintain its meaningfulness.
Yes, I agree with you a 100%, yeah.
So, you start this thing off.
You're you're doing it.
You're not sharing anything about it
until you reach a certain point.
Yeah.
And then you decide to kind of break public
in this whole thing.
Yeah, actually, that's a good point to bring up,
because for me, this was not meant for social media.
It was just for myself.
And it was Lex Torres Belle, my fiance,
when I started this running streak, she was like,
"I think we gotta do a YouTube video.
This is really cool.
You're running everyday and you're going for a year.
People need to hear about this."
I keep pushing it off.
I was always pushing it out.
So, on day 163, she came to me and she said,
"Hey, do you wanna do a YouTube video on this?"
I was like, "All right, fine.
You keep asking, let's just do it."
I had just done my run for the day.
So I said, "Can I just go to the barbershop
and get my haircut and get this like nice face,
so I can look pretty in front of the camera?"
And then I went to get my haircut, came back.
We did a video.
And the title was "Why I Run Every Day: Day 163."
And I started explaining to people.
So, that video actually sat on YouTube for a month or two.
It wasn't a lot of views, couple, maybe 20, 30 views.
So, one morning I woke up, it was like 2000 views overnight.
And I was like, "Belle, look at this.
This is really weird.
Why is this catching on like this?"
And then we see 20,000 views overnight.
And that kinda went viral.
And it got over 600,000 views really quick.
And everybody's asking me,
"Are you still continuing the streak?
What's happening?
Can you update us?"
So, my DM on Instagram is getting flooded now.
Comments on YouTube is getting up.
So I said, "Well, let's keep updating people."
And I started doing updates,
day 254, day 365.
And then we just became YouTubers by accident.
So, one of the things I was afraid of
that turned into passion.
And now that turned into something
bigger than I ever imagined.
Yeah.
And Belle really drives that, right?
She, without her, there's no hellagood.
She's the one who's doing everything.
A 100%.
So, basically, she dropped whatever she's doing
to help me chase my dreams and goals.
She never went to school for a filmography or photography
or anything.
She just self-taught even editing.
Just we started doing it together as I'm running
and sharing the passion with everybody,
and she's recording it.
And she got better with kinda get the content.
You can see the evolution from the early videos-
Yeah, to now.
Through the present, how much she's grown at it.
Yeah, so, and in fact, she would be like,
"Oh, this is awesome."
(Rich laughs)
We look back and I'm like, "Oh, okay."
It looks, you definitely got so much better.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's cool.
And some of those videos have millions of views.
Yeah. Yeah.
A few of them went viral.
We've had all the running every day for a year,
the three years and the 1000 days, day eight or two.
So, we had a few of them over a few million views,
which was really cool.
Yeah.
So, you meet the 365 goal.
You did it for a year and you're like,
"I'm gonna keep going."
Yeah.
So, how long had you been doing it
before the idea of running across America
came into your brain?
So, it was two years in.
So, after the first year I knew I wasn't gonna stop,
but the thinking was, can I do it again?
Because now I know everything to expect the season.
Because the goal is to be outside,
no matter the circumstances,
raining, sunshine, snow, I have to run outside.
If I will run on a treadmill, it won't count.
It's extra run, but it's not counting toward my streak.
I have to be outside.
That was my biggest goal.
So, after that second year coming up,
you knew what to expect.
So, it wasn't as joyful to the first year.
Everything was new the first year.
You're like, "Whoa, this is happening.
New discovery."
And I got hurt the second year.
So, but in the second year, it really hit me quick,
"Hellah, this is bigger than yourself.
You proved to yourself that you can run every day
for a year.
You learn on year two, that's gonna be a daily routine.
Do it for something that's bigger than yourself."
So, and I realized quick how running is a privilege
that not everyone has,
and I wanna use that privilege of mine
to do it for something greater.
So, the ideas of doing it for things, even doing races,
I don't care about my own PR numbers.
I wanna have a reason to go fight for.
So, if I'm dining out there,
I'm thinking about why I'm running.
So, I'm sitting home one day and came out of the shower.
And I said, "I think I wanna run across the country.
Has anyone one done that?"
And again, I thought I was gonna be the first one.
I have no idea.
Clueless.
And she looked at me and she goes, "Oh no."
'Cause she knows when I try to do something,
now at that point, I have to do it.
And her, she's like, all right,
she started doing research for me.
And then that's when we discovered Robbie Balenger.
Right.
And that's how the idea of running every day,
running across the country came up after year two,
when I said I needed run across the country.
Right. All right.
Well, we're gonna get into that in a second,
but I have to ask, during this couple of years
when you're running every single day,
there's some travel in there too, right?
Oh, yeah.
Like you had to go to Australia,
like how are you making sure that you're not missing a day?
That day, yeah.
There's some tricky moments in there,
where it was touch and go,
whether you were gonna able to squeeze it in.
Yeah, so, so many times I've flown,
I would get up 2:00 or 3:00 in the morning to run.
So, I wanna be in control of what I can do.
I don't wanna go to the airport, get stuck at the airport,
or I don't have a mean to get out to run.
So, I get up very early to run.
So, they'll show the opportunity cam with GoPro.
And I told GoPro, "No, I'm not going."
To Australia.
Right. Yeah.
Yeah, and I said, "I'm so sorry this is great,
but because of running, I-
I can't break the streak.
Yeah, because of running, I met you guys.
It's very important to me to run.
And to go to our show, it was like 27 hours.
I'm gonna miss a day.
So, they find a way to connect me with a travel agent.
So, I set up the trip where I don't mess up my streak.
So, I had to take a little more flights than everybody,
so I can keep my streak alive.
So, where you like flew to LA first
and took a day so you can do a run.
Yeah. Yeah.
Stayed in LA.
And then on midnight in LA,
the day before I went to Australia.
So, I got up at midnight.
So, it was the next day.
It was midnight already.
I kept everything at Eastern Standard Time
instead of Western too,
because I didn't wanna get advantage
of the extra like hours into the day,
like three extra hours.
So, I wanted to make sure I get the same 24 hours as I left.
So, I ran an LA, took a day.
And the next day at midnight,
I got up to run right before I went to the airport.
Literally ran, shower, and ended up running
to get to the airport because I almost missed my flight.
So, I end up doing two extra miles that night
to get to the international section of LAX.
So, now I landed in Brisbane.
And Brisbane was, from LA to Brisbane was about 15 hours.
And then when I got to Broome,
immediately I got off the airport, we got to the hotel,
I went to run again.
So, it was still in the same time zone.
You maintained the Eastern time zone as the anchor.
And the cool part about that
is though it was still the same day in East Coast,
but just later in Australia,
about to be into this following day.
So, it was really cool.
Right, it can get confusing.
Yeah, it's confusing.
I did a whole YouTube video to explain it to people.
So, that was how I kept my streak alive, going to Australia.
And what's the typical run?
The typical run in terms of distance?
Yeah.
Yeah, so in the beginning,
by accident, I ended up averaging over seven miles a day.
My first year was 2,800 miles.
And then I had that mentality,
now I wanna run seven miles a day.
That's like the mile that doesn't break me, but it tests me.
But it's just enough that I feel like I've done something.
And second year I was injured.
I just missed five miles a day average.
And then a third year, I was averaging over 10K.
And because of the transcontinental,
I averaged over eight miles a day for the whole four years.
So, my favorite mile is going on a seven-mile run
because something that kinda tests me, but doesn't break me.
The sweet spot.
Yeah, it's the sweet spot.
Yeah, is that what you did today?
Today no.
I did five miles today.
Okay.
All right, maybe you have to get out
and do two more.
Yeah, two more.
We can go out right now.
Do you have your shoes? (laughs)
(laughs) I might have my car.
Yeah. (laughs)
Cool.
So, the idea for the transcontinental run
comes into your awareness,
a great opportunity to make this about something broader
than just maintaining a streak.
A streak. Exactly.
How did you become aware of Robbie?
So, again, Belle, I'm telling you without her,
I wouldn't even be probably sitting here
talking to you today.
She just started doing research.
I had no idea.
She goes, "Hey, Hellah, there's this runner
who's actually plan-based running across the country.
He's gonna be literally in our backyard
to start in New Jersey to go to New York."
She said we should go meet him.
I was like, "Yeah, let's do it."
So, my goal to go mid-ride
was just to run five miles with him.
I get there, his energy, I said,
"There's no way I can only do five miles.
I have to do the whole 17 miles with him."
So, that's how I met Robbie.
And when I first met him,
I told Robbie, right then I said,
"Hey, Robbie, I'm so-and-so.
I run.
This is really cool."
And I said to him, "I'm gonna run across the country."
And then he looked at me and he gave me the look of like,
you know what, the way this guy just said that to me,
I think he's gonna do it.
(Rich laughs)
'Cause when you say something to somebody,
you get the energy how they might think,
"Oh, no, you can't."
Or you're crazy.
He was like the look that he gave me, it almost was like,
I think this guy might actually try to do this.
So, it was the best time.
I interviewed him.
I had my GoPro with running
and I asked him a bunch of questions.
And that's how the relationship started with Robbie and I
and how it's just like being there firsthand
to see what he was going through the last day
kinda gave me even more motivation
and more belief in myself that I can do it.
Yeah.
So, was that last run into New York City
the same route that you took?
Similar.
Very similar.
So, he ended in a park that wasn't far away from my house.
Literally, if I were to run through the park,
I'd get to him in like five minutes.
So, we had to drive around, which was about 10 minutes.
So, we ended in similar area,
but in the opposite of each of the area.
And then a route that I took eventually kinda got into haze
to finish into New York City.
Right.
Yeah.
It's so serendipitous.
Like he's on your radar and he's literally gonna go
right through your backyard.
Yeah, and it was meant to be.
It really was because what are the chances
someone running across the United States
ends up being where I live?
Right.
And I had it in mine.
So, you ran the whole last day with him.
I ran the first day with him from a Haiti beach.
Yeah, he told me about that too.
I knew of you already.
I'm like, "Wait, wait, wait,
are you telling me Rich Roll came?"
(Rich laughs)
He said, "Yeah."
He told me the whole story.
And I said, "Wow, that is incredible."
Yeah, that is cool.
So, we book-ended it.
And then he becomes like this mentor
who helps you figure out the logistics
of how you're actually gonna execute on this.
Exactly.
And the thing is, you know the saying
it takes a whole village to raise a child, it's true.
Even for me, without having Alexa Torres Belle to help me,
my friend coming to drive, Robbie being there,
it would have been like almost impossible.
So, he basically told us he's experienced
and we're looking at his route on Strava as well.
He used the famous racing route.
But it was easy to also just go look at his map
instead of looking for that map itself.
And we had to kinda find our own route within it
at some point, but we basically using his blueprint
to get through.
There's so many different routes.
Yeah, so many.
I mean, your route took you pretty much through this.
It's more of the southern route, not the full south route.
Yeah. Yeah.
Toward the southern.
Yeah.
Why did you decide to take it that way?
Well, first I thought coming from west to east,
the tailwind would help, which we had zero tailwind
but also seeing that someone already done it that way,
Robbie has done it that way.
And it was kinda, it makes you feel better.
Like, you know what?
This is like it's not like you're the first one
paving this route.
So, you kinda have a little bit of a breathing room
to kinda follow a route.
So, that's why we decided to do it.
And then looking at the rocky mountain area,
the weather now was predictable.
And when we actually start within Houston storm,
where everything was shut.
And we're always thinking what will happen.
Will the RV get stuck?
in the snow and the mountains.
What happened that I can't even get through,
'cause there's like walls of snow.
So, that was always in the back of the head.
So, it made sense for us to go in the southern states.
Also tons of vert.
Yeah.
Right?
There's that too.
That too, for sure.
Not for nothing,
do you know what Robbie's doing right now?
Yes, Robbie is crushing it at the Colorado run.
It's literally called the Colorado crush.
I mean, this guy is doing,
he did the Leadville marathon the other day.
Right now he's in the midst of conquering
the Colorado trail, which is 500 miles.
Then he's gonna run the Silver Rush 50.
Then he's gonna summit all 58 Colorado peaks
over 14,000 feet.
And he's gonna complete this challenge
with the Leadville 100 and on August 21st.
Incredible.
It's unbelievable.
I said have to find a way to get to him
because I love you.
I'm gonna call him.
He doesn't stop.
I'm gonna say, "Hey, Robbie,
do you need me to come run with you or be next to you?
Or whatever you might, I owe you that."
But he doesn't stop.
That's the kinda people you wanna put yourself around
because he just gets it done.
Did COVID have any influence
on doing this now versus later-
Yes. Yeah.
Just because everything was locked down
because this is something that you could do or?
Definitely did because I actually wanted to do in 2020.
And that's when the whole,
like literally the country was shutting down
and nothing's happening.
And for me, I wanted to make sure that people were involved.
I wanted to be not just about me,
about creating a community, creating something positive
because all this stuff were happening in the world.
So, I wanted us to come together as humans
and having running and combat
or not just being with each other.
So, when COVID started,
I kinda was thinking, you know what,
maybe we should wait and keep pushing it off,
'cause I want people to be involved with it.
And actually, I was saved for myself,
because yes, mentally I was ready,
but physically, not to think back at,
I don't think I was really ready.
Because within that year of COVID,
I started doing more ultra distances.
So, I did my second 50 miler.
Crushed the pro by 30 more minutes faster,
I did a 245 mile a week
where I was running 35 miles a day.
(sighs) That's a heavy week.
Yeah, and then that's why I got the idea,
maybe I can do it a 100 days or less,
because with that, I didn't even do much
like the way I would do five-mile segments.
This one, I was doing 17 miles, 11 miles,
and get it done within three miles, 35 miles.
So, that kinda helped me be stronger
and build kind of some kind of endurance
and running strength for ultra distances.
And then 2021 comes and we took things into full gear.
Yeah.
It's one thing to just go out
and run five, seven every day.
It's a complete different world.
It's another thing to prepare for a transcontinental run.
But how, other than what you just mentioned,
like how did the training differ
from just maintaining that streak?
Completely different.
That's Robbie also, right?
Robbie is the man
I talked to him, he said, "Hellah on too."
He said, "Run slow."
And he even recommended me,
"Go walk for two hours and have your legs just be heavy
and beat up."
You want that feeling because that's what's gonna happen.
You always wanna run on tired legs.
Yeah, exactly.
So, I was, to me, I went out to run into zone two.
It wasn't slow enough.
It was slow compared to what I was doing really slow.
And into myself, I'm always like, "Man, I'm going so slow.
I could have done this many miles."
You play this game with yourself and your head.
It was much slower than compared to what I was doing.
Yeah, but that's how you build the true endurance
and that aerobic energy.
Yes, exactly.
That aerobic engine that you're gonna need.
Yeah, and I'm glad I even did what I did
to even get what I got out of it.
I just, I could have even went slower than I did.
So, I made sure that I focused like two to three months
doing that prior to starting this.
So, it's not just like this pace that I run
because it's not a middle-distance or long-distance sprint.
This is ultra.
Ultra game is different.
Yeah, it's a totally different thing.
Yeah.
Did you periodize the training at all?
Not really.
Yeah, I just went into it
and I made sure that I was gaining some weight.
And I started strength training more.
I started lifting weights.
And usually I don't lift weights as much.
I tried to do body weight strength training.
Doing like even resistance works.
I started lifting weight.
I added a few more pounds.
And I was just making sure that I get out there and running.
I was running like even a 100 mile a week.
I've started doing that.
Started doing mileage where I would never do.
But that was about it.
Just making sure that I was running
and then having strength.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I want to snack a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know
actually already know how to eat better
and aspire to incorporate more whole plants.
More fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans, and lagoons
into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support,
very few end up sticking with it.
So, because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience some version
of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is The Plantpower Meal Planner,
our affordable all-in-one digital platform
that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious, and easy-to-prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now, for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership
when you use the promo code RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life-changing stuff, people,
for just a $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com.
Promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off an annual membership.
All right.
Let's get back to the show.
It's interesting when you watch your videos,
especially the one that you did on technique,
like run technique, to see the change in the evolution
in not just your stride, but like your body.
Yeah, everything changes.
When we see you crossing the finish line
in New York City, you're like a skinny lean.
You look like a runner.
I lost. (laughs)
In those early videos, you're like,
this is a soccer player.
A soccer player, buddy.
With stubby legs and the whole thing.
It's amazing to see the body transformation.
Everything changed.
And just the natural kind of stride that you have.
You're like, "That guy looks like he knows how to run."
Yeah, everything changed.
And that goes in with time too.
So, I tell people if you're getting into running,
it's gonna eventually change.
Just stay consistent with it.
Yeah.
Yeah, everything changed.
Losing the weight is just gonna happen.
You just gotta make sure you eat as much as you can.
And I remember actually last summer,
I was training for a 5k PR.
So, I lost weight just because just sweating a lot,
just naturally.
Didn't even plan on doing it.
And I remember someone on my YouTube channel actually,
who has like a 10,000-something streak day.
Yeah, he lives in Michigan.
I can't believe I'm blanking on his name now.
He's like a good friend of ours,
like on YouTube always commenting.
And he said, "Hellah, you have a race body now.
This is the race weight."
So, you just lose weight by just running.
Yeah.
So, the idea is to try to get this done in under a 100 days.
Yeah, that's the goal.
But secretly.
I wanted 85 days.
85.
Yeah.
You got it done in 84.
84, yeah.
Which means how many miles a day?
Just over 36 average.
But the crazy thing for me to think about it,
the first half to get to the first half of the country,
it took me almost 50 days.
The second half I did it in 34 days,
which show how much I had really had to go through
in the mountain.
The mountain areas really beat me up and slow me down.
I was talking to Robbie a lot.
And he said, "Hellah, my advantage was I lived in Colorado.
I was always running in the mountains."
I live in New Jersey, 92 feet above sea level.
My whole, almost three, four years of running every day,
my elevation gain I don't think total was more than 4,000.
Right.
All pavement and hills.
Yeah, and I call those hills massive speed bumps.
I don't think they're hills.
They're not at all.
(laughs) Yeah.
So, you went through this acclimation phase
of having to get fitter,
while also your body trying to get used to the pounding
and the vert and the different types of weather.
I know your feet like swelled up and all kinds of stuff.
You went from like a size 10 to 11 and a half.
To 11 and a half, yeah.
Wow, man.
Yeah, and the knee was swelled up,
ankle was swelled up and shins were flared,
blisters everywhere.
And the running in there.
And me, I went in,
Robbie warned me too.
I've had warnings.
And you kinda like, you learn your lessons.
He told me, "Hellah, get these sticks."
Checking sticks.
So, I was laughing and I was like-
Poles.
I said, poles, yeah.
I said, "Robbie, who needs a pole to run?"
'Cause we have like a comfortable relationship.
Like we joke around.
And he said, "Trust me, it's gonna make a huge difference."
So, I get them there with me,
then use it in California at all.
So, me being me, I was running up everything.
And I was listening to "Born to Run" in the beginning.
And it says in "Born to Run," for ultra racing,
if you don't see the top of the hill do not run it.
It is wasteful energy.
It's not gonna take you anywhere.
You think that down hills are gonna help at that point,
your legs are beat up.
You're not even making any progress.
So, I was running everything up.
That's when I messed up my knee and ankle became a problem.
And in my hip was so out of line,
it was like two inch above the other.
My right knee versus the left knee.
So, I had to really, I called Robbie.
I said, "How did you do this?"
He said, "What are you doing?"
I said, "Yeah, I'm running everything."
He said, "You're not supposed to be running everything,
Hellah.
You cannot run up these."
And then you're gaining.
At one of my run, I gained-
You're not going any faster anywhere.
You're not.
I'm literally slowing myself down.
So, I kinda like got into the ultra,
listening to "Born to Run,"
actually taking tips from then,
calling Robbie if I have any question.
And I got stronger as I was going.
Technique was changing, strategies were changing.
And that's why I had a better, stronger April month
compared to March,
where I basically went from 876 miles in March
to 1,225 miles in April with one day less.
And even the elevation gain was worse in April
compared to March.
It's amazing how the body can just get used to that.
Yeah, figure that.
Figure it out like originally,
you're having all these problems 'cause it's like,
"What are you doing to me?"
Yeah, exactly.
Right?
You make a few tweaks, you keep going,
and suddenly those things get resolved and-
It all comes together perfectly, yeah.
So, throughout that whole experience,
I mean, hit me with some of the highlights.
Yeah, the best is like going through
the Navajo reservation in New Mexico was incredible.
So, the message travel.
If I meet somebody,
by the time I get to a different part of the reservation,
they already know I'm coming
because someone will say something.
They're all talking, yeah.
And people getting ready for gifts.
Someone has made me a necklace,
that we're getting feathers,
has a gift like telling us what the meaning behind it,
key chain.
And even Belle got a gift.
Garrett got a gift.
So, and I met the first person to come and run with me
was Zack from the Navajo reservation.
He was a native.
And he came when Robbie came the same day.
Oh, wow.
So, he said, "Can I run with you, Hellah?"
I said, "Yeah, of course."
So, we ran 15 miles together that day.
And then he said, "Can I get your number?"
And I said, "Yeah, sure."
So, he texted me and said, "Can I get your location?
I wanna come back again."
He came back the next day and ran 30 miles with me.
So, that was really cool.
That's when people started coming in at that point.
And it was just incredible.
Just like the beauty of the reservation,
New Mexico and the people itself,
that was one of the biggest highlights.
Yeah.
Do you have to,
I remember talking to Robbie
about going through the Navajo Nation.
I mean, it can be tricky, right?
Yeah.
Like it's not just a free fall.
Like do you have to alert them ahead of time?
Like, "Hey, we're coming, is it cool for mission?"
Certain areas, yeah.
Just sort of shake the hands
and make sure that sort of-
Yeah, we didn't have to deal with that much,
but there was one time that a lady stopped us
and told me, "You gotta wear a vest.
You can't be running on the roads without wearing a vest."
I only would put on my kind of safety vests at night-
Reflective, yeah.
Reflective vest at night, so I can be seen by cars.
But during the day, she's like, "You gotta put this on."
And she explained to me about people drinking and driving,
you don't wanna get hit.
And she was like, "You have no choice."
Like she's like, "Do this now."
So, with respect also, I'm like, "Well, it won't hurt me.
It's just extra safety."
So, we put it on.
But there's been areas
where we've got invited to used people's land
to have RV park overnight.
Yeah, because there's nowhere to park.
It's not safe.
And then those are open land that people owned.
So, they're like we had a gentleman say,
"Hey, can you come in?
You can come and park your RV overnight
'cause I have no use of that space.
You can."
And was it just you and Belle?
That was the crew?
Was there anybody else?
Yeah, so, it was me, Belle, and Garrett, my friend.
So, he was driving the RV.
He would go every five miles ahead in the beginning.
So, Belle would be indexed to me,
literally the top of my eight to 14 hours a day,
in a support car, driving a RAV4, a crossover,
where she would be the one doing the direction.
I'm not good with direction.
She'll tell me, "Turn when you get to this area."
And I'm like calling her on my Apple watch,
"Hey, what street I'm supposed to be turning?"
But she's next to me for that.
And like fluids and any snacks or food I need.
And also for safety too.
Safety from dogs and some people as well.
Because there has some people-
Yeah, I wanna talk about that.
Also, shooting, editing,
and taking to the social media the whole time as well.
Yes. Yeah.
Doing all of it.
So, I think if you were to ask me even now
who had the hardest job, I'd say she did.
'Cause my energy just had to be solely focused on running
and just feeling myself, eating and running.
Hers is like everything.
She basically held everything together.
She really did.
There's an illusion that if your crewing an ultra event,
that's chill,
you're just in the car and you're listening to tunes,
it's full court press, there's so much to do.
I don't think there's any time, no.
You have to be thinking ahead.
You have to be thinking about tomorrow,
where are we gonna get food?
Do we have ice?
Anticipating what your needs are gonna be.
And also, you're gonna be so exhausted
that you're not the best arbiter of what you need.
Exactly.
Like this guy needs to drink.
(Hellah laughs)
He tells me not thirsty.
You gotta force yourself on all that kinda stuff.
Yeah, that's exactly it, yeah.
To a point where I was thinking,
make sure that she is not stressed.
So, my goal was to make sure that she is good,
because if she's not good, I'm in trouble.
So, any little thing that's coming up
that I could see could end up being bad,
I make sure that, "Okay, are you good?
Are you good?
Are you sure?"
She gives me the thumbs up, yeah, she's good.
So, we move on.
Because without her, I would have been in trouble.
I'm sure you've heard the trope
that you should never have people you care about
crew for you for these things because it gets dicey.
It gets tense.
You're a very optimistic.
You got this sunny disposition,
but I would imagine you were in the pain cave quite a bit.
Like did you ever break character
and go into that dark space?
Actually, I tried and I don't think I did.
So, what really helped me before this,
I told myself, "Hellah, anything that happens,
any hardship that happens, you have to accept this
because that's part of this.
Even though you haven't done it,
you know something's gonna come."
So, the fact that I accepted that,
so my thinking was always when something happened,
Hellah, Soles4Souls.
Think about that.
The reason to doing this as much bigger
than anything you've had to go through.
Whether that's pain or anything,
any little problem, hiccups.
So, I will always remind myself that.
And I'll do my little gratification in the morning
when I'm doing my first mile, I just telling myself that.
So, I always kinda stay away from that.
And we did really well together as a team.
We really never stepped on each other.
And in fact, she kept me in line.
Like, "You have to eat.
You don't wanna do this?"
And she listened to my problem, anything I like,
"Oh man, my legs.
I don't know if I can make it to 30 miles today,"
she'll listen to me.
I remember one day when I really realized
she's gonna not take anything easy on me,
when I had to do 47 miles.
We started at 47 miles.
I get to mile, was it mile 40?
I had 40 miles in.
I had six months ago.
And it was night pitch black.
I look at her, I'm like, "Yeah, I still got six miles to go.
I don't know what to do."
In my mind. I'm hoping, she said,
"Just do three more and we'll call it a night."
She goes, it is, she literally looks at me with no smile.
With a CS look, she goes, "It is what it is.
We gotta get six in.
And it's gonna take you two, three hours.
We gotta get six in."
And I was just like, "Ah." (laughs)
(Rich laughs)
You're not getting out of this, Hellah.
Start moving now because you're wasting time.
So, she wouldn't let me kinda cave in because there's been,
if she wants to tell me, "Just shut it down there,"
that's all I needed to hear that day.
That's how exhausted and whatever I was.
And I'm glad that happened
because that gave us a little bit of a leading way
later on in the day
when I had other things come up.
It was perfect.
Yeah.
You mentioned Soles4Souls.
I know Buddy Teaster a little bit.
I've spent a little bit of time with that guy.
He's awesome.
What an amazing person.
So, talk a little bit about that relationship
and why that organization.
Yeah, so, I grew up in West Africa, Mali.
And having shoes literally is,
having shoes here is a luxury thing for people
because you can have it and then it becomes luxurious.
Like you just don't need shoes just to have shoes,
so you're safe, your feet are safe.
It's more about more than that.
In Mali, that's not the case.
So, we need shoes.
It's a safety thing.
I grew up playing soccer in dirt, like grain, like pebbly,
and then there's metal scraps here and there.
So, you would cut yourself.
I have scars all over my legs, even the bottom of my feet.
So, not having shoes is a big problem.
And when you get shoes, you have to take care of it.
If you don't, the next one won't come out
for two to three years, sometimes even five.
And sometimes it's not even
that you don't take care of the shoe.
You outgrow it and you gotta wait till the next one
you have the opportunity for your family to get it.
Because it's not about shoes.
It's about you being able to eat and survive.
And I was very lucky to be one of the family
that could get shoes for you.
But it doesn't mean
that I get shoes all the time too either.
So, I realized that.
And I'm thinking to go for a run,
all you need is a pair of shoes and it can change your life.
This has changed my life.
And Belle again, started searching what nonprofit
really could relate to me as a person
that I wanna run for.
And she found Soles4Souls.
It's like perfect for you.
Yeah, it was a perfect match in heaven, literally.
It was the best thing that we could identify.
And we started with so many amazing nonprofits out there,
but we wanna make sure that something that relate
and something that could make a change.
And the one thing, what they do
is they collect unwanted shoes, used or new,
and they turn it into opportunity.
And they're trying to use shoes
to break the cycle of poverty.
And what I really love about Soles4Souls
that got my attention immediately,
was that not only did they help all over the world,
through our country or whatnot, they also help in the US.
Because living in the US,
I'm very proud to say I'm a US citizen.
And I still see that sometime we tend to forget
that even here, a first-world country,
people don't have shoes to wear.
So, the fact that they catered to that,
they look out for here and other places of the world
is awesome.
And it's not even being selfish in a way,
because my mentality is if you take care of yourself,
then you have the ability to take care of others.
So, I like that they're helping everyone in the world,
also here in the US, which is really cool.
Yeah, it's a really interesting model
because they have this distribution mechanism
where all over the country,
there are places that you can drop off your shoes,
new or used.
And they funnel all of these shoes into distribution outlets
all over the world.
I mean, Africa is probably the most prominent continent
where they distribute these.
But they don't just give them to people,
they basically donate them to entrepreneurs
who can then sell them at an affordable cost.
So, you're not just like, it's like the thing of,
are you gonna give somebody a fish,
or you gonna teach them how to fish?
Right?
They're teaching how to fish.
So, you've given these people a way to make a living
by doing that.
Exactly. Yeah.
And I saw this family's story in Haiti,
where this lady couldn't afford to feed her family,
let alone pay for her kids to go to school.
Now, because of Soles4Souls,
she had a little business for herself,
can feed her family and can pay for her kids to go to school
on top of that, which was really cool to see.
It's coo, yeah.
It's like the perfect organization
for you to be affiliated with.
And I know Buddy came and ran
the final day with you, right?
Yeah, he came forward different occasions.
Yeah, Buddy being the CEO.
He wasn't the founder.
He came in maybe like five or six years ago, right?
Yeah, he came in actually 2012.
Okay, a little bit longer than I thought.
Yeah.
Yes, I'm pretty sure that's when he came in.
And being an ultra runner and having him with me too,
having ultra runners with you was a game changer
because you are getting these little like tips
that are helping you to last longer in the day
to get this segment done quicker.
And they pace you very well.
And pacing doesn't mean to rush you to go faster,
but they pace you where like these little idling time
and things that you waste, you don't waste these anymore.
Did you have a bunch of ultra runners dropping in on you
throughout the whole thing, other than Robbie?
Robbie, Buddy, Noah.
Noah was an ultra runner from Pennsylvania.
There was not many ultra runners, but a lot of runners.
People actually are running, and people who weren't running.
And they came out to put their body
through uncomfortable situation to help you.
It makes you feel really grateful
that people are doing that for you.
Yeah.
Well, you've had other mentors as well.
I watched the video,
where I think maybe Gymshark produced this video,
where he did a Zoom call with Ross Edgley.
Oh yeah, Ross.
Who is like the best, right?
Yeah.
I loved that.
And he's a friend.
That guy, I mean, talk about another beast
who's also just a font of positivity at all times.
And he said something really interesting to you,
which is that from his perspective,
the differentiator was gonna be Belle.
Yeah, he was right.
And he was right about that.
He was a thousand.
When he told me I knew that she might be a big help,
no matter what,
but he was like super a 100% right.
It was just without her, I don't even know.
Yeah.
That's the difference between-
I think we might be still on the road right now
trying to get back to-
She didn't come out with you to LA, did she?
No, she didn't.
Yeah. Yeah.
I would've liked to have met her.
We'll meet up for sure with you one day.
Well, it's one thing,
I've had Robbie on the show, obviously.
I also had Rickey Gates on,
who shared his experience running across America,
self-supported, which is a very different thing.
But a key difference here
is that these are two white dudes, right.
And they're out there, they're vulnerable.
They're in parts of the world.
And in so many ways, if you're gonna do this,
you're relying on the kindness of strangers, right?
Yeah. Yeah.
As far as I know, you're the first black person
to do this, right?
Yeah, to do this solo.
Yeah, so, I did research to figure out.
So, back in I think 1928, there are these,
I think it was three or four runners.
I'm not sure.
So, they were running across the country,
but they were doing a relay.
So it was-
And it used to be a race.
It was like a long time ago.
Yeah, it was a race, yeah.
It's literally called Race America or something.
And there were black dudes in it, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, they're actually kicking out
some of the black runners or color runners.
They're like, "You're not doing this."
But they did a thing where it was a relay.
So, like, let's say me and you did a relay together.
You do certain amount of distance.
So, I'm the first solo black person
in the history of the country
to run from LA to New York City.
Did you know that going into this?
Going into it, I had a conversation with Robbie.
Robbie actually brought up to me, he said,
"Hellah, I don't know, I think you might be the first.
I haven't seen in."
And Robbie was making sure he was doing his research
so we don't come and make such statement and it's not true.
But yeah, I started thinking about it as I was going.
And that's when I kinda got a little nervous
with some of the things that's happening in the country.
So, I asked Robbie, so I called him one day, I said,
"Hey, what was your biggest fear?"
So, in my mind, I wasn't even thinking anything else,
but I was just thinking about being a color person.
So, he was telling me about the dog situation right away.
And I brought up the whole
like should I feel not safe for who I am?
And then I knew that was something that I was concerned of.
And you can see why you were concerned about
when you're in certain parts of the country.
But overall, I tried not to put my energy into it.
So, my mentality is, if you put your energy into something,
that's what's gonna happen.
You're gonna manifest it.
So, you're just, yeah, you're coming into
just positive people.
And I would say majority of that, 95% of the time,
that was the case.
Right.
You did have a few run-ins though.
Yeah, I had a few run-ins.
The first one actually happened in Oklahoma,
which was really scary for me as that.
So, when we were in California and Arizona,
I've had these awesome police officers,
"Hey, you're the guy on TikTok.
I saw you on Instagram.
Can I take a picture with you?"
I remember this officer,
I saw him one day outside of Flagstaff, Arizona.
And then 30 miles later, he saw me the next day he goes,
"Whoa, you're really making progress."
And he asked Belle, "Is it okay if I stop Hellah
to take a picture?
Is he gonna be mad?"
And I was like, "No, I'm not gonna be bad."
So, he came in.
I was like, "Yes, thank you so much."
I was always taking pictures with them.
And one of the officers coming in Oklahoma,
and I thought it was similar thing.
Maybe they know what I'm doing.
So I'm excited.
I'm running.
Actually, I was cruising that day.
I'm like I have my stick.
I'm like smiling.
And then I see the officer come out.
I thought he knew what I was doing.
But everything kinda got serious immediately.
I can see it.
So, he just said, "Hey, sir, I just got a phone call,
there's a runner on the road.
What are you doing out here?"
And with the seriousness of the voice,
I was like, I don't think he's very happy right now.
And immediately-
Is it a busy road?
I mean, a charitable interpretation would be that
like why is this guy out here?
Like it's unsafe or something.
Yeah, it was in the middle of nowhere.
Not much traffic to a point where like Belle
could be next to me for most of the time.
If anything, she's a little behind or a little ahead.
It wasn't that busy.
It was in the middle of nowhere
with the next town being five miles ahead of me.
And immediately he said,
"I got a phone call there's a runner.
What are you doing out her?
What's the point of this?"
And I said, "Oh, I'm actually running across the country."
He said, "For what?"
So, what got me scared when he put his hand on his gun.
And then you know that there's like a clip in the-
Yeah, yeah, the little box.
So, I started panicking and I put my stick up
and said, "Well, this is just a running pole.
It helps me get up the hills.
And see, I'm wearing my safety vest.
I want people to see me.
I'm doing it for a nonprofit."
And I just started telling the story.
And I started waving Belle in.
And I was scared to wave Belle in early
because I didn't want him to think that-
You're calling somebody else.
I'm getting help,
and now he has to be protective of himself.
So, I was scared.
So, I kinda waited even a little longer to wave her in
because she was actually thinking later to find out,
she thought it was just an officer,
just seeing if I was okay.
Oh, 'cause it's been the case.
And then I see these couple far, and these are two couples.
And I was like, this is weird.
I think they were waiting for me.
So, they got impatient with my interaction
with a police officer.
At that point he was asking, "Can I see your ID?"
I said, "Well, my ID is in my RV, five miles ahead.
I gotta get to that."
And then he said, "What's your birthday?
Give me your name."
And he's just started asking me all these things.
He was a little annoyed.
But these couple came in, these white couple came in
and they're like, "Are you Hellah?
Our son told us about you.
We were tracking you down.
We wanna donate."
They had money for me.
They wanted to take pictures.
Then I see the officer buying into the story.
I can just see, he's like,
"Oh, he is actually doing this for real."
Like he literally can see it.
And I was like, "Thank God these people came in
so they can attest to what I'm doing
'cause they've been tracking and following me."
And I was waving Belle at that point.
So, she came in.
She would come over with the camera all the time
to get content.
And the officer asked me then, "Can I also get a picture?"
Yeah, and I was like-
At the end of it-
It just turned into a positive.
And thank God that happened.
That was scary.
It's kinda heavy, man.
It's heavy that a couple of white people had to come in
in order for this guy to feel okay about what was happening.
Yeah, and when he left, it hit me I was shook.
I couldn't move for like 10 minutes.
I was in the side of the road.
I was like, "Wait."
'Cause I just started thinking, why was he touching his gun?
And the reason I raised my pole, 'cause I'm thinking,
I hope no one thinks that's a weapon or a rifle.
I don't know.
So, you just started thinking all of these things.
So, I was shook a little bit and that was tough.
And also in actually around in California, I had this lady.
I think the lady was a little cuckoo.
This lady goes by in a Jeep and she offered me water.
She said, "Hey, do you want some water to drink?"
I said, "Oh no, I'm good.
Thank you.
That's my support, actually,
I got my water in there."
And this lady also is coming up screaming at that car
for offering you water.
And then she goes, "What do you think you're doing?"
I said, "I'm running across the country."
She said, "For what?"
I said, "For a nonprofit called Soles4Souls."
She goes, "Well, that's bullshit.
You're about to get cut up now."
I was like, "Wait, is she joking?"
So, I was like, "Belle, wait, wait."
Cut off?
Mm-hmm.
I was like, "Belle, wait, wait,
I don't know if she was joking or not, unlock the car."
And then I'm across the street and she's on the other side.
And she started charging sprinting.
And there was a gentleman next to her.
She was like, "Come."
I thought it was her boyfriend.
She's calling her dog to come.
So, I just sprinted into the car and Belle did a U-turn.
It was the fastest U-turn I've ever seen her do.
And we just whipped around and she starts to chase the car.
And I see her in the...
I'm turning around, she's chasing the car.
And she couldn't keep up.
So, I was kind of, I was thinking in my head,
there's no way she can catch me right now.
My leg was good enough to run faster than her,
but I'm like, if she has a weapon or a gun,
I can't outrun that.
So, we call an officer and we waited two hours.
The nearest officer was like almost an hour away.
So, we had a two hours Officer Laker.
That was her last name.
She was so cool.
I was, "Oh, Laker, I like that last name."
She came and escorted us.
And by the time she got there, they were gone.
But we just wanted to be safe and to get through that area.
So, that was in California?
That was in California in the beginning.
And a lot of people were warning us to be careful there.
Yeah.
And last sad story,
and I don't like to talk about sad stories so much,
was Missouri.
Missouri was one of those places where,
to begin with, I was already like,
"I don't like Missouri because of snakes."
Literally, people were asking me,
"Have you seen any snakes?"
I was like, "No, there's snakes nowhere."
And we get into Missouri, snakes on side of the roads,
on the grass, everywhere, in front of you.
You can see road kills, it was really sad to see that.
So, I'm like, I don't wanna...
One of them jumped in front of me too,
and I panicked and screamed and just took off.
So, that was already in the back of my mind,
I'm running, I'm like looking at the side of the road,
I hope there's no snake.
And I go by Owensville High School
and school was just getting,
I was around 2:30, 2:40 PM,
all a bunch of kids pulling out of the parking lot.
So, me, whenever I see cars, would always wave.
Like I say, just give good energy.
Some cars, they kind of move through so far over,
even over the white line
and you feel like you're gonna get hit.
So, I'm always trying to keep tight
and also waving at people, I'm here, but also,
"Hey, hi, how are you doing?"
And I see these truck poles.
And then it was a bunch of teenagers,
bunch of boys in the back of the truck.
And the pickup truck has a window that rolls down
in the back windshield.
So, I saw one of the kids stick their head out
and call me the N word.
I was so shocked.
I was like, "Wait, did this just happen?"
So, I'm just like, "Come on, what was the point of this?"
So, Belle across the street thought they were gonna hit me
'cause sometimes that happens.
So, she just hunks all the time to warn people.
She just thought it was one of those.
And they just ended up kid ducks down and floors it
and just took off.
And I'm pretty sure a parent saw it
because she definitely felt bad.
She came back around to wave at me
and basically said, "Hey, I'm sorry that happened."
So, that happened in Missouri.
So, that was really...
And I got flipped off a little bit in Missouri
prior to that.
So, that was not a fun day in Missouri.
Yeah, I'm sorry that that happened.
But overall people were charitable and awesome.
Oh, what I realized is there's so many more good people
in the world than bad.
And it makes you feel like we have a promising world
because so many awesome people that don't even know who I am
were offering me water, they're offering rides
to a point where like I was denying rides.
One lady comes to me and say,
"Well, I won't tell anybody."
And I was like, "No, that would be cheating."
Like that's how good people were.
Bringing Gatorade, they're like, "Well, I saw you.
I'm like you're not just running a few miles.
It looks like you're going somewhere far."
So, they would bring me water.
And so many good people, so many.
It's cool.
Yeah, did you watch Rickey Gates' documentary,
"Cross Country?"
No, I don't know if I saw that one.
You gotta check it out.
Yeah.
I mean, because he was doing it self-supported,
it's just him.
Oh, he was the one holding the...
Yes, I saw it.
I did. I did.
And so much of that movie, it's not about like,
it's less about the running part
and it's so much about these encounters that he has
with all these people along the way.
And there's like one guy wants to give him money and like...
And so, and part of the impetus
for him doing that run when he did it,
was being this like liberal, progressive guy
who grew up in Boulder, Colorado.
Oh yeah, he did a "Transamericana."
Yeah, exactly.
Yeah, I saw that.
I watched that so many times.
Yeah.
He wanted to really get a feel
for what America actually is outside of your Twitter feed
or what you see in your respective information silo.
So, I'm curious, outside of these bad experiences
that you've had,
like what your take is on the temperature of America.
Like we're gonna share this on July 4th weekend,
we're celebrating America.
America is in a situation right now
that I would characterize as transitionary at best.
Like we're very divided.
And we're struggling with our ability
to communicate with each other effectively.
We are, see, there are different worlds out there
that see things very differently.
And it's easy when you're staring at a screen
and kind of taking account of what people are saying online
to form an opinion of what's actually happening.
It's a very different thing altogether to be like,
I'm here on the ground.
And I went all the way across America.
And I had conversations with all of these people.
And this is what my perspective is
as a result of having had that experience.
Yeah.
I think a 1000%, America is much better
than we see on social media.
A 100%.
I really like it's just,
there've been many days it was so filled with love.
And you really like to feel love,
like it's the energy we're literally sitting in the RV
in awe like, "Wow, this just happened."
We saw biker go by,
and then she's asked Garrett in the RV what I was doing.
She baked vegan cookie.
Made sure it was vegan 'cause she wants to research on me.
And came in to even tell us the ingredient too,
so we can trust her.
(Rich laughs)
And came in and found us at a rest stop
in a Navajo reservation.
And she was a doctor or a nurse.
So, people giving, like you said, money,
literally giving money.
"Oh, you're doing it for this?
Here's money.
Here's cash."
And it's so much more better.
It's so much positivity and love and caring
that I personally felt than I saw from being in New Jersey.
And being there, you see it for yourself.
And you can see some of these people don't even have much,
and they're still trying to make effort
to make me feel better, to donate, to support.
Someone was even saying,
"Hey, you look like you can have some lunch,"
when I was running across the country.
I was like, "Nah, I'm good."
He said, "Just take it."
And I said, "You know what?
I'm gonna donate this money exactly to the nonprofit
I'm running for."
And he goes, "It's perfect."
Never seen me.
Doesn't know who I am, what I do,
but they just wanted to help.
And seeing that, that's what I said,
we have a really promising future.
That's cool.
Yeah. Yeah.
That's encouraging of you.
It's beautiful.
It is.
And then I said 95% of the people, 97 that we've run into,
it was all nothing but positive energy and love.
Different background, different race, different gender,
or whoever they want to be accepted as,
but you just felt like you were just one.
And I would ask people questions
without comes and run with me,
and I realized we're all the same.
We all have the same goal.
We have passionate dreams and goals we wanna accomplish.
We wanna be able to take care of ourselves, our family,
and friends.
And it's just in a different way.
So, I think we are doing a lot better
than what we see right now.
That's to my personal opinion.
I hope so, man.
I hope so.
Well, talk to me about the vegan diet thing.
It's a whole other like layer to this story.
So, me going vegan over five years now,
was five years late February.
So, Bella went vegetarian the year before.
We watched "Earthlings" together.
She's bawling her eyes out.
She said, "I can never eat animals."
So, she went vegetarian.
So, I grew up in West Africa, Mali,
where I've seen people sacrifice cow, sheep,
and even was part of holding the legs
for it to happen as a child.
They make you do that.
And you're basically forced into this culture of meat eating
without even having a choice to.
And that didn't do anything to me watching "Earthlings."
And then when I went back to look at it,
I'm like, "Man, I was sick to watch this
and not change my last."
I was even sad watching it.
But fast forward to a year later,
she wanted me to watch this documentary
called "Forks Over Knives."
So, I said, "Let's just do it."
I gotta start listening to her,
because every time I listened to do something,
it ends up being amazing.
And we watch it.
(laughs) Why is that?
I don't know.
She's just amazing.
She's incredible.
So, 20 minutes into "Forks Over Knives,"
I remember this vividly.
I looked at her with my mouth dropped.
She goes, "Are you okay?"
I said, "I don't think I'm okay
because I don't think I could ever eat meat
for the rest of my life, but I'm scared.
I don't know what to eat."
And she said, "Don't worry about it.
We'll figure it out."
So, we went vegan together, cold turkey.
So, I made a decision right then, I'm never eating animals,
seeing what it does to people,
seeing professional athlete being on plat-based
and doing their stuff at the elite level
and I'm an amateur.
If they can do at an elite level,
why can't I survive being who I am and not eat animal.
So, I became vegan for selfish reason.
And now it's more than that.
It's more ethical for me too as well.
So, I'm glad it took that
for me to realize what's happening in the world,
even our climate or whatever.
But the only thing I regret about going vegan
and being plant-based is I didn't do it soon enough.
That's the only thing.
Yeah, that's interesting.
So, you were doing it before the run streak-
Yeah, the run streak, yeah.
When you were still in the professional soccer world.
Yeah, actually, right when I turned vegan,
I want to play in Oklahoma City for the Oklahoma City Energy
there in the USL, the lower division,
just the division below MLS.
And I got there.
I used to get kicked out of practice.
I'm not kidding you.
Wow.
I had this energy that my body just started feeling
and I just couldn't explain it.
And my teammate would look at me, "Are you crazy, Hellah?
What's going on with you?"
I remember one game at a locker room.
Half time, one of our teammates goes,
"If you come in this locker room and you don't feel like
you haven't left everything on the field,
you're not exhausted, that means you didn't play."
So, I humbly raised my hand.
I said, "I disagree with that
because every game I've been giving all my all,
but I still feel like I can play a second game."
That's how much energy my body just felt.
So, just because I don't feel tired
doesn't mean I didn't leave it all out on the field.
And I used to,
that energy, it was just people.
And I started convincing my teammates to go plant-based.
Then I had to do this.
I just don't eat animal.
My recovery time is quicker and things like that.
And I can feel it.
How long before you had that experience
after making the switch?
I switched a month later.
I went to Oklahoma to play.
It was like about a month later.
Wow.
Yeah, literally.
Switched in February or March.
1st of April I was in Oklahoma.
So, recovery times are better
without running out of energy.
Not like petering out in fourth quarter
or late second half or whatever.
As being young, we would be up to 2:00, 3:00
in the morning, we wake up, everybody's exhausted,
like, "I don't know how we're gonna survive practice."
I'm like, "I feel like I got enough rest."
And then when I started seeing them like,
"Wow, I think it's my diet.
It has to be."
'Cause I was a big chicken person.
In fact, I'd have leftover chicken from night
and eat it as breakfast that morning,
like 8:00, 9:00 in the morning, which is really-
They wanna kick you out of practice?
Yeah, my coach would be like, Hey, Hellah,
you're done for the day."
'Cause the second team that doesn't play a lot,
they practiced longer to get more fitness
and gamma underneath them.
Oh, 'cause you had to play, he didn't wanna burn you out.
Yeah, that's why I got kicked out of practice.
So, I would go join them to do extra practices.
And my coach would,
or like easy day where we don't play much
and I wanna stay long, he's like, "Hellah, you're done.
You have a game in two days."
And I wanna stay, but I always get kicked out,
'cause I had that energy with me
I think because of plant-based.
Do you know this soccer agent called Daren Flitcroft?
Heard of him. Heard of him.
Yeah, he's a friend of mine.
Oh, really?
But he's super plant-based.
Oh, wow, that's cool.
And he's a big mucky muck in that soccer agenting world
or whatever.
But he's like gung-ho plant-based.
Yeah.
And a fun fact actually,
so my neighbor, Samuel and his girlfriend, Roberta Greiner,
who was actually was ranked in Doha for- four marathon
as he was running six in the world.
Wow.
So, they saw,
I kinda started telling them about the whole vegan thing.
So, that surprised me with your book "Plantpower."
Oh cool.
Yeah, so, I was literally consuming your book.
Oh, good.
Before the transcontinental.
Oh, that makes me feel good. (laughs)
Yeah, I have your book at home.
So, they'll give it to me as a gift.
I don't have it list for my birthday last November,
but it was, they say here's a book.
I was like, "Oh, Rich Rolls?"
I didn't know you had that book.
So, superfood, so there was a chapter with the superfoods.
So, I was just saying, "Okay, Hellah,
you're tending to run across the country now.
Yes, you're vegan.
So, now let's add more superfoods
because now you're doing something
that your body is not used to.
So, I need the food.
So, again, thank you for having that out there-
You're very welcome.
For all the plant-based people out there.
No, I'm glad that I was able to contribute some small
into this from afar.
So, what did the daily nutritional situation look like
when you were running across the country?
So, my, I had sponsors, Vivo Life, which is a 100% vegan
their mantra is, "For the living."
Like out of the UK.
Yeah, UK, yeah.
For the living.
And the reason I wanted to work with them
because they plant trees every time someone buys something.
So, over 250,000 trees in a year from their sales.
So, they kind of asked me,
"Hellah, can you write out all the stuff you eat?"
So, there was a nutritionist there.
So, I kinda did.
And they kinda put that in together.
And I told them what I wanna eat.
Some of the stuff I looked at in your book,
this is what I wanna get myself.
So, we were doing like a practice feeling.
Like stuffing myself, being uncomfortable,
running with food in my hand to eat and train that.
And so, my biggest thing was bagels.
I love bagels.
But I got sick of bagels.
So, but I was eating a lot of the rice whole.
It's hard to eat.
Well, you can pour water on them and they go down easier.
But while you're running, you can try bagel.
I don't know about that.
Yeah, exactly.
So, I was leading a lot of the rice bowls,
the fresh veggies, avocado.
Belle was really creative with the food
to make me more interested in it
'cause my appetite would change.
I would be obsessed with certain food.
Within few days, I can't even look at it or smell it.
So, we were eating a lot of whole foods and a lot of green,
everything you can imagine,
and hydrating with electrolyte mostly then water.
Yeah.
Did you have a Vitamix on the RV?
We had a blender, but not a Vitamix
because we were scared is it gonna use all the power.
Yeah, because it requires a little bit more power.
Yeah, a little bit more power, yeah.
But then you use a normal blender,
it's not the same thing.
Yeah, it's not the same thing.
Yeah.
How much of the intake was liquid
versus like solid foods?
Actually, I'm actually surprised,
I was eating more solid and liquid.
So, my biggest liquid would be at nighttime.
So, we would do a Ben & Jerry's vegan ice cream,
where she would pour that with oat milk.
A 1000 calorie.
The Ben & Jerry's was 990 calories.
And with oat milk, I had to get over 1000 calories.
Blended, I eat my dinner and I just chugged that.
(Rich laughs)
So, I was getting-
The Ben & Jerry's vegan ice cream.
Yeah, that was the best for me, for liquid.
And then now we started having the electrolytes
that has calories in it to drink that,
to making sure that when I'm drinking electrolytes,
I'm not just drinking for the electrolytes,
but I'm getting some calories off of it as well.
So...
And what kind of heart rate were you maintaining?
I was trying.
My goal was keep it below 140.
Do that.
So, people would come-
Low zone two.
Yeah.
I mean, I don't know what your thresholds are.
Yeah, people would come run with me
and then they kind of start pulling away,
and start to be like, "Don't do it, Hellah.
Because you have to not just survive today,
you have tomorrow and the next and the next day to see it.
You're playing the long game.
Yeah, they're just here for the day.
'Cause then they don't do it on purpose.
They just like kinda, you just drift away somewhere
when it's a group of people and I just stayed behind.
I said, "Yeah, you guys can keep going.
I'll see you when I see you."
How was the sleep?
I couldn't sleep.
That was the problem.
I'd always wake up tossing and turning at night.
It wasn't because the RV bed was uncomfortable.
I thought that was the most comfortable bed,
but it's just that I just can't sleep.
I wake up at 2:00 in the morning,
up for two hours and I'd fall asleep.
The alarm is ringing 6:30.
You gotta get up.
So, I think on average,
I got less than five hours of sleep the whole time
for the 84 days.
Were you're wearing like a WHOOP
or any kinda tracker that could give you some data on sleep?
I just used my Garmin.
And I used to wear a WHOOP,
but I didn't bring the WHOOP with me.
I used to have that, but I just used the Garmin
and just went off of.
'Cause to me, even when I was using WHOOP,
it would tell me to take a day off
and there's no day off for me.
(laughs) Your strain score is 20-plus today.
Time to time to give it a rest.
Yeah, exactly.
That's not now what you wanna hear.
You've got 47 miles ahead of you.
Exactly.
I love my Garmin.
I think is the best precious I've done.
It does everything that I need to do.
It also tells me all of these numbers
that I needed to know for my body.
But every time I started started run,
it says, "Suggestion to rest."
Take a day off. (laughs)
Yeah, and it will say to me,
"Your fitness goal, take 12 days off."
I'm like, "Wait, I can't do this.
There's no day off for this.
You gotta get up and go."
And so, the technology will tell you,
"Hey, you're doing too much training,"
but you just gotta keep pushing through.
I was talking to...
Did you follow the Iron Cowboy dude?
Oh, he's amazing.
James, I talked to him.
Did you talk to him?
Yeah, I talked to James.
He actually DMed me too.
And then he's like he congratulated me.
I'm like, "Wait, look, do you know what you just did?"
Oh, it's cool.
Yeah. I love.
And I was trying to see if I can,
we were thinking, oh, is he gonna be in my path?
So, I joined him.
And then we realized he's in Utah.
So, that was out of the question.
So, when I got back, I was trying to see if I can get to him
and do some miles with him, but I didn't get the chance.
You wouldn't be able to meet him.
Maybe I wanna meet him one day.
Yeah, I can look that up for you.
I showed up on day 91.
I saw that.
I was so jealous.
I'm like, "Oh, Rich is there with... "
It was pretty fun.
Yeah.
But he was telling me,
'cause I asked him about his sleep as well.
And he said that his sleep was terrible.
It was terrible during this thing.
He would have night sweats and night terrors.
He would sleepwalk like he was all jacked up.
Like he's like, "I never have nightmares or night terrors."
But it was like a really weird thing.
So, even though he would be flat on his back,
he wasn't really actually sleeping
because his body was so traumatized
by what he was putting it through.
In shock for me too.
I can't even imagine for him,
'cause he's just an incredible doing all that,
getting up and repeating.
And you know what's fascinating to me about what he did?
For me, what made it very fun to,
you know you're making progress.
I'm going east, no matter what.
Every mile is counting.
Except some days when you're climbing up,
you're like, "Ah, I'm not even going east yet."
But he has to do his in the same area over and over.
Right.
It would be like you waking up in your house in New Jersey
and doing a 40 to 50-mile loop every day, the same way.
Yeah, I think huge props to him mentally,
just to be well to sustain that.
Because you're in the same area, it's not changing.
It can get boring.
It could be whatever.
And he still did it.
And I wanted what it was the next day.
I saw and I'm like, "What's happening?"
Because he just wanted to blow people's minds.
Yeah, he did.
And the point is made,
that even when you meet your goal,
like even when you do the thing that you
and probably nobody else thought was possible,
you still have more in you.
Exactly.
There's always one more.
And where this transcontinental,
what I really learned is where I knew this,
but like we're really much stronger than we think we are.
When you're put in an uncomfortable situation,
you'll find a way out if you have no option.
So, my mentality, get comfortable with the uncomfortable.
And this is what really taught me.
So, if anyone who's struggling with anything right now,
just stick to it,
because eventually there'll be a turning point.
You just have to fight through.
Fight the day.
And there's been many days
where I'm just like, "Survive today."
I don't care about tomorrow, what happened yesterday,
just survive today.
So, it comes down to that.
So, when you would have those days,
when you would wake up and you're like,
"There's no way I can do it,"
walk me through the mantra or how you get yourself
into the mindset to be able to put one foot
in front of the other.
First, I didn't call majority this time.
So, when you get up in a warm RV, you do not wanna get out.
Literally am like, I don't wanna go.
I would get up.
This is the time I actually, I guess,
when you asked the question have you had your breaking point
where you just, I would just talk to Belle,
I'm like, "I don't wanna go."
When I'm saying that, I'm not even joking.
I'm like, "I don't wanna go.
I can't do this.
I don't wanna do."
I keep repeating it.
And then I would say, "Hellah, stop, wait a minute.
Because he keeps saying this,
your mind is just gonna keep believing.
Your body's gonna react to it."
But a lot of the morning, I just get up,
I'm just like, "I don't wanna do this.
I don't wanna go."
And I'm like Soles4Souls.
Soles4Souls.
Then I keep repeating that in my head.
But getting out of the RV was the toughest.
And even the hardest part after that,
when Belle brings me to where I dropped the pin,
where we ended the run.
And I was always make a sign and put arrow NYC
and we see a street.
If I finished my miles and I don't see any street,
I keep going until I see the next street sign
and we drop a pin just to make sure we're there.
When she brings me to drop me off there, the next morning,
getting out of that, leaving the warm car,
I like, I wanna cry. (laughs)
(Rich laughs)
But as soon as it started going,
then you're like, "Okay, this is not too bad."
But that was the hardest, to get up and get out.
Was there one specific low moment that sticks out?
Like your lowest moment that almost break you?
Two lowest moments for me
was the first full day in Arizona.
I got into Arizona at a later day,
where that night I finished.
But the first full day in Arizona, it was a switchback.
And I gained 3000 feet in six miles, which is really weird.
Think about that.
3000 feet in six miles.
Yeah, yeah.
How is that possible?
Yeah, that's a lot of game.
Yeah.
And then it was, so, the goal,
the thing was mentality for me is fall off the cliff
or get hit by a car.
That was like the only two options for me.
I felt like it was.
And it really was
until we had to put me in front of Belle's car
and she was holding up traffic, and I'm just in front of it.
If you can get around,
when you have the opportunity, go ahead.
If not, you're gonna have to wait.
Like having her go at six miles an hour in front of me.
So, as I switched back in Arizona,
where I'm just climbing and there's this cliff.
You see cars that fell off of this cliff.
You see them there.
Like old cars, rusted-
Down the Ravine?
I don't even remember the mountain name.
I can't believe I can't think of it right now.
But it was our first day.
And we keep climbing and I went through everything.
I went through rain, I went through hail, snow, wind.
All seasons within that, getting out of that mountain.
And I was in there for like 13, 14 miles.
For the first six miles. I think I gained over 3000.
And it was basically to a point
where like I felt like I'm going up,
someone is pulling me back and you're gonna fall backward.
And you hunch to use your pull to get you up there.
And the cars, it was dangerous for her, even with a car.
And I see these cars coming down.
And you can see cars on top.
Like, it looked like a stairs.
How did they get up there?
And you just see how steep it is.
And we Google it, why do they have switchbacks?
That's even to help with elevation.
That how tough that is.
Yeah, it is too steep to go straight up.
Yeah, I killed my knee really like-
Is that when you were still trying to run the hills?
Yeah, I was still in the running.
(Rich laughs)
Yep.
That's why I did it for me.
And Missouri, there's a raining day,
where 15 miles an hour ahead crosswind.
And I would get out.
It was freezing cold out.
I would get like soaked in water in my shoes.
I can feel puddles in my shoes within two, three minutes.
And I couldn't move forward.
I'm trying to progress forward.
I can't move forward.
It was very stressful.
And I would get into the RV to get out,
'cause I'm shivering to get...
I can't even get warm by running.
To get out of my work clothes to get into new clothes,
which was a bad idea because as soon as I step outside,
it felt like I didn't even change.
And that was tough.
That was like really tough for me.
That's the day Belle went on Instagram and said,
"Hey, Hellah is struggling today.
'Cause I want people to know the reality.
It's not always sunshine and rainbows.
If you guys just wanna send him a message,
he'll probably appreciate it."
I'm glad she did that because seeing people come in,
sending me messages is really cool.
But those two days I'll never forget because that was-
That's wild enough.
Yeah, those two days was tough.
What's the recovery routine?
You have the NormaTec boots, you have a Theragun,
or the Hyperice.
A Hyperice massage gun and the NormaTec boot
is really nice.
And I had a machine called Kelvi.
So, I don't know if you've heard of Kelvi.
Uh-uh.
Ooh, I gotta get you hooked to Kelvi.
What is that?
So, Kelvi, have you ever heard of Game Ready?
It's like ice and water, how they wrap your leg.
So, Kelvi is a machine that can go to 160 degrees
within two seconds.
And that can freeze to 39 degrees within four seconds.
Wow.
And it can contract-
So, you alternate back and forth between all them.
You can do conscious.
It'll go hot for three minutes, cold for two minutes.
Or as you can switch the times.
Or you can just keep it on cold the whole time or hot.
So, that was really helping me with recovery.
And every time I checked-
Are they like boots like NormaTec?
They're not boots.
It is like a console and it has like this wrapping
where you can wrap around your knee or ankle.
So, it's completely different than NormaTec.
But every time I actually did NormaTec, I felt it.
Every time I didn't put it on I'm like,
"Why did you do this, Hellah?
You know when you don't do it, you you're paying for it.
So, many nights when I-
These things work.
It works.
It's magic.
It feels like you have a new leg.
So, I had this time in the day at 2:00 PM, 2:30,
where I put on normal tech.
So, that's when I really cruise from 36 miles
all the way to 47.
Sometimes I would do that.
I've done that many times actually nonstop without breaking.
I would just go straight for it from 36 to 47
to call my day.
Yeah.
But more often than not, taking a NormaTec break
in the middle of the day for a little reboot.
Yeah, it's a huge reboot.
It really is.
So, I was so happy that I had that to my availability.
So, now that you have this in the rear view mirror,
like what else did you learn about human possibility?
Like where did your mind change from before to after
in terms of how you see yourself
and how you kind of think about possibility in general?
So, I always, like sometime we sit there
and be like, "Wait, I just ran across the country."
So, it hasn't gotten old to me.
I hope it doesn't.
You just kind of realize that we're not limited.
And I think of Eliud Kipchoge when he said,
he still says that no human is limited,
and sometime like, yeah, we're not limited.
And I truly believe that because you find your limit
and you break it.
I cannot run Eliud Kipchoge marathon time.
It took him 20-some years to get there.
But I have my limit,
but I can break that and find another limit.
If I wanna do that, I have to spend years on it.
So, it really reinforced that we are not limited.
We have a limit right now within ourselves,
but we can reach that and breakthrough
and find the next limit.
So, I feel like I found my limit doing this
and I broke through it
because it was time where I thought it was impossible.
I even thought a hundred days was not even enough for me.
And then I broke through that limit
and now it makes me think that I can do other things.
So, I wanna do Leadville 100.
That's the next thing?
I wanna do that.
And I'm gonna actually trench.
Are you gonna show up on August 21st when Robbie-
I feel like that might be a little too soon. (laughs)
My body is not still there yet,
but I wanna focus my time actually go in the mountains
and train.
So, it really makes you feel like we are much stronger
than we think we are.
And whenever you think you are strong as this,
you're stronger than even that.
So, if I'm thinking I can do this,
I can even go beyond that.
Just always think even beyond that,
because you'll be able to do it.
Even if it takes a little longer than someone else has done
and whatever,
but you'll be able to find the power
and the will to get through it.
Just like the Iron Cowboy doing 101.
Incredible.
I cannot wait to meet James.
I wanna ask him some questions
and things like that staff they're doing.
I'll introduce you to him.
Yeah.
Talk to me about the mantra that's on the t-shirts
and the...
I wanna talk about the bus. (laughs)
Yeah, that was really cool.
This phrase, no matter the circumstances,
what is that about?
Like, why did you hone in on that
being that kind of like the touchstone
or the moniker for the adventure?
So, when I my run streak, I said,
"You're gonna go outside and run 10 minutes a day,
no matter the circumstances."
Whether that's the weather, whatever it is issue I had.
I was still having a 9:00 to 5:00.
You wanna get up early and run before work,
or you wanna run after work.
So, circumstances are gonna prevent you
from getting out there.
So, the mentality was no matter the circumstances
from LA to New York City,
whatever happened, you gotta make it happen.
And to a point I was thinking,
even if I have to crawl like a baby on my hands and knees,
if that's the only way I'm gonna move forward,
it might take 200 days now, but I have to make it happen.
So, that's where no matter the circumstances,
I wanted to preach that to everybody.
Every single day, I said,
because if we wanna do something, we can make it happen.
So, we just gotta push through whatever circumstances
come our way, good or bad.
Because circumstances doesn't always have to be bad.
It could be like, "Oh, I'm at a party."
It's a great circumstance right now.
(Rich laughs)
But you gotta get your work in,
no matter the circumstances,
you gotta get out there and push through.
Have you always been this guy
who's inspiring everybody around him?
Did you mature into this?
And when you were a kid, were you like this?
Where does this come from?
I think the fact that I grew up in West Africa,
I really quickly grasp on,
I have a really good, I have my best friends' kids,
my age that are in Africa that'd do anything
to be in my position.
So, what's not there to be happy when in life?
Like to me right now, what is life?
I'm sitting across from the Rich Roll talking.
So, there's little moments in my life that I think about
or major moments in my life that I think about,
no matter I'm going through any little tough time and say,
"Come on, Hellah, just a time frame that's gonna go by."
So, what really makes me push through anything
and just always have a smile on,
when there was times where I was really struggling,
nothing was going my way,
and I thought that was the end of everything.
I really thought like your future is done.
You have nothing to look forward to.
And I'm sitting here.
So, whenever I go through a tough time, I just laugh.
I say, "Remember that one time you thought this is it?
Look at that."
And vividly actually,
when I signed my first professional contract in 2013,
as a professional, you get paid, right?
So, imagine a professional that is signing a contract,
has no money in his bank account even to eat.
And you don't have the got to reach out
to family members, to friends.
How are you gonna ask for money to go get groceries?
You just signed a professional contract.
So, I remember one day playing in Seattle.
I have a game coming up.
And I want to buy food.
My card was declined.
So, I get home and I look at my bank account.
I was $0.
So, I didn't know what to do.
So, I called my bank, I said,
"Hey, can you guys allow me to overdraft?
I will get paid in two weeks."
'Cause they would pass biweekly.
"And I just wanna overdraft.
You can charge me the fee."
And then the lady that was with me said,
"No, I can't do that for you."
So I said, "Please, just allow me to do this."
And she said, "Let me connect to the manager."
So, the manager came on
and I wish I can find who he is today.
But I talked to him.
He goes, "I'm not gonna allow you to overdraft."
He said, "You know why?
Because if I allowed you to overdraft,
what happens if you don't pay?
The fee adds up.
Next thing you know, you're gonna be negative
and owe a lot of money."
And he said, "You know what I'll do?
I'll give you $30 credit right now so you can go get food."
So, I go get a week worth of groceries.
Like Aldi was cheap store.
And I think about that day,
because that day I was really like,
I'm an athlete I have to perform, but I didn't have food.
I couldn't even ask my teammates.
And so, thinking back to all those times, nothing really,
adds more to you just wanna smile
because I really have it good.
I'm able to run every day, realizing my dream,
which is running every day.
It's a privilege of mine.
I have two legs.
I have two limbs.
And even running every day is a privilege
because there's people who can't walk, let alone run.
And in the back of my mind, I'm doing it for them too.
It's not about me anymore.
So, I can't do anything, but be happy.
Be excited.
And it's life.
Life is really beautiful.
Even though we have these little bumps along the way,
but overall, having people around you, family, friends,
and having because of social media, I have a big family now.
'Cause I'm like I have now all these people
around the world.
Cool people.
I know you, I know James now.
I know all these incredible.
It's just, you can not smile.
You really can't.
That's beautiful, man.
I love the gratitude and the appreciation.
Thank you. Yeah.
It's very infectious.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Does the village back in Mali know what you've been doing?
Like have you talked to anybody back there?
Actually, yeah.
So, the funny thing is my dad actually forbid me to run.
He told me, he said, "Hellah, I forbid you to run?
What is this run nonsense?"
(Rich laughs)
He said that to me.
He literally said, what is this-
How old were you when he told you that?
He told me this in 2018 running
when I was just two years in.
'Cause I went back to Mali and I was still running.
My sister was getting married.
I was so good at my running.
And he said, you're gonna...
He was sending me videos of people dropping dead
in soccer matches.
And then he said, "This is what running will do to you."
And it's funny because he was the biggest supporter
for me to play professional soccer.
So, I said, "Dad, what's the difference?
Those professional soccer,
if I was playing professionally,
would you say the same thing?
Because I'm still running.
It's just that maybe you like one versus the other."
And he basically told me, "I want you to stop this running,"
since he never was supportive.
And my mom was more like I'm concerned for my child.
Don't hurt yourself kinda thing.
But things turned around.
And then my little brother would said,
"Dad, I think Hellah is doing something
that is gonna be great because he's doing it for himself
and other things."
So, now he's one of the biggest support.
He said, "Hellah, now I understand."
He was so proud of the whole run across the country.
He was so happy about it.
In fact, he wrote a note to have my sister read it
at the finish.
And basically saying, "I have three PhDs."
My grandfather, Hellah, that's who I was named after,
he said he was a peasant,
but he find a way to get out of the situation
and make himself who he was before he passed.
And then he said, "You top all of us.
You ran across the country."
And he said, "May the legend continue."
Now he's like one of the biggest support.
He goes, "Now I get it."
And he goes,
"I don't even know where you got the genetic from
'cause it's not for me.
'Cause I can't run this much."
He couldn't believe that I was doing that many.
We're talking about at 1.75 kilometer in kilometers a day.
So, now he's fully behind it.
But now the whole country,
basically most of the people that I know in Mali
are like, "Wow, this is incredible."
But the biggest part for me
to have like kind of an understanding
and not even have to be supportive, just understanding,
was my dad.
And now he's all about it.
That's cool.
Well, given that he was such a tough sell,
it's all the more meaningful, right?
Yeah, he was not about it at all.
He was not, yeah.
(Rich laughs)
But now it's completely different.
He's always saying like, "Oh this is awesome.
Proud of you."
And then he's like, "I saw this article."
So, now he kinda see the bigger picture
that I always had a vision to do something for others
and not just about me.
And now he can see that.
He wasn't sold on the YouTube thing either.
Oh yeah, YouTube, no.
(Rich laughs)
In French, they say mannequin.
Mannequin is basically like a model.
He said, "What is this modeling stuff you're doing?
Showing your body, running on YouTube.
What is that?
What is that gonna do for you?"
Yeah, he wasn't about that too.
Now he binge watched my YouTube videos. (laughs)
(laughs) That's great.
Yeah.
Even I'd make fun of my sister.
There's no hard feelings at all.
So, my sister, the reason I'm telling this story
is because people are not gonna support you.
Even the closest ones to you
are not gonna understand what you're trying to do.
My sister told me this, Fadima, she's listening to this.
She knows it's all love.
I love her.
But I was joking around with her.
She told me, "Why don't you stop this stupid YouTube thing
and get a real job?"
She said that to me one day.
It really hurt because you're like, man,
this is someone that's closest to you.
And then I was able to get my plane ticket,
to go to her wedding, which is like a last-minute notice.
It was a month before.
"I'm getting married in Mali, can you come?"
I used the YouTube money that we had.
It was not mine.
It's Belle and I.
We do this together.
She said, "Just deposit into your account."
We've never touched anything from YouTube.
It was just enough for a plane ticket.
So, I bought tickets to go to Mali.
So, when I got to Mali, I was like,
"Fadima, how sad would've been
that your own brother couldn't make it to your wedding
because he couldn't afford it,
but well, thank God for YouTube." (laughs)
(Rich laughs)
Did she come around now too?
Now she's been super supportive.
It didn't take long for her to understand.
That was in the very beginning stage.
That's cool.
Yeah, she even came at the finish line with her husband
and my nephew.
And you're making it work.
Yeah.
In terms of like making a living on YouTube
and supporting yourself.
You've got these sponsor relationships.
Yeah, which is really cool.
Like I couldn't,
like even I remember one day actually,
I was laughing really hard.
And Belle's looking at me across the road
during the transcontinent.
So, she said, "Are you okay?"
I was like, "I'm just smiling.
Because look at this.
What is life?
We're able to do this?
We don't have to worry about anything.
Like we we're good.
We have food to eat.
We have a sponsored Gymshark
that gave us a mobile home, the RV.
We have a sponsor, Vivo Life, is paying for our food.
Like this is incredible.
Why can I not?
Like I can't just stop smiling about it."
So, I am grateful to say, because of my sponsors,
I'm making a living.
I can do this full-time.
I can travel around the world
and we can create content anywhere we go.
And what I let people understand is it's not even YouTube.
Because for YouTube, for us, this is the shrift.
Truth about it, you don't really make enough on YouTube.
Well, I don't.
To live, you cannot.
It's more about because I love.
There's a lot of illusion around that.
Yeah. Yeah.
Like if it was for money in the beginning,
we would have quit a long time ago.
It's just, I love sharing my passion with people
to let them know you can have your own journey,
whether that's running or not, or anything else,
and just stick to it and get it done.
And, but what YouTube did for us
is brought the opportunity to be signed by Gymshark
as the second ever runner and to be signed by Vivo Life.
So, those sponsors allowed you
to be able to be a little more flexible with yourself
and at least make a living in terms of you can eat,
you can have a roof over your head.
And do the thing.
Yeah. Yeah.
Do the thing that you love, right?
Exactly.
Those guys showed up for you.
I mean that bus on the final day, talk about-
Yeah, Gymshark, he really went all out.
Go to his Instagram or his YouTube
and watch the final day.
I mean, that bus is unbelievable.
It's a party bus with crazy tunes.
It's crazy, yeah.
I mean, like there's people on it
like riding into the city.
Yeah, they had the rap all done.
And they did the RV too.
The rap, no matter the circumstance.
And in French also, peu importe les circonstances.
And they had that whole thing.
They had a permit to shut a whole street down
in New York City.
They had police, NYPD, escort them, warned them to get us.
And my town really showed up Rochelle Park, New Jersey.
I had a town mash it up.
Yeah, whole town.
The deputy mayor.
I didn't know that was happening.
I go around, I'm like, "Wait, is this for me?
What's going on"
The firefighter with a big American flag,
which was a problem for me because no matter what,
America made me who I am now.
Because of America, I got the chance
to me living the American dream.
Because I came from a place where nothing was very promising
and now I'm living the American dream.
So, when I saw that flag, it hit me hard.
Like a big flag.
It was like bigger than the whole fire truck.
They had like a ladder holding it hang down.
So, seeing the town show up
and having Gymshark support, Vivo Life support,
is just, you always think, "Wow, what, this is happening."
And I was joking with everybody who would arrive.
I was like, "Should I run across the country again?
'Cause this is exciting just to see. (laughs)
(Rich laughs)
I'm gonna have to do this twice again."
Yeah. Yeah.
It was cool seeing you go into Manhattan.
The roads, were they shut down?
Like which avenue were you going up
where it was just a huge perception of you guys in the bus.
Yeah, so we turned onto second street.
And then Belle called me and said,
"We're gonna have a police escort.
So, keep the left side of the road."
I was like, "Okay, okay, we'll follow the rules."
So, we turned and this police officer
just pulled in front of us with the sirens
and then slowing like traffic
like literally opening the road to us.
So, it just became a whole party literally.
The music is blasting from the bus that Gymshark had,
the cutoff top.
And-
You're dancing.
We're dancing.
Everybody's basically dancing on the road
'cause we would have to follow now the traffic light.
So, we get to our traffic light,
we have to pause the run because the crossroads
and the police would stop and we'll stop
and people would start dancing.
Everybody, bystanders, people like recording.
People like getting out of their car, like what's going on?
They don't know what's going on.
And it was just amazing.
At one point actually, we took over the whole street.
No one could even drive on it.
We stopped at a light.
I saw the officer,
the passenger officer comes out of the car,
I'm like, "Oh, oh, we're in trouble.
He's gonna probably tell us to keep one side."
'Cause that's what I was instructed to.
He comes out with a cigar.
He goes, "Hey gentlemen, I just wanna let you guys know
we're about to make a left on 50th street,
and that's where the finish line is."
And everybody started shooting
because we were not in trouble.
He literally came out, he basically-
That's New York cops.
They're the best.
Literally the best.
He came out to let us know
that we're about to get to the finish line.
And I thought it was
because we literally took over the whole road.
It was amazing having everybody come in.
And when I was doing that last run, I called Robbie.
I said, "Hey Robbie, I want you to be next to me."
'Cause I thought it was a full circle.
I was there for his last day.
He came out for me and throughout the transcontinental
and he's there for my last day.
I said, "Robbie, step up, let's go."
And then I had Garrett.
I said, "Garrett, get up here."
So, Robbie was like, "Garrett, get up."
You can hear in the audio on the video.
I just wanted them to be in the front with me
because it was really special.
And then for some reason, I found the strength.
My legs were-
You looked fresh.
You did not look tired at all.
I know.
I was like, how did this guy have so much energy?
I just started working it.
I saw that, I'm like, "Okay, get to it right now
as fast as you can."
And I looked at my split laid on my Garmin.
It was 707 pace at that point
from running 12 miles in a minute mile to 707.
That's great, man.
Yeah, for the last push.
And how long had you hatched plot
to pop the question at the finish line?
I wanted to do it as soon as I started talking
and thanking everybody and the sponsor,
everybody for just being there and making this very special.
So, I told Robbie as soon as I said, "Hey, Robbie,"
that's when he...
Robbie had the ring.
Oh, he did.
He's the ring bearer.
Yeah.
So, I said, "Hey, Robbie."
He just grabbed it
and he actually gave it to a friend of ours, Lex Woodshop.
She hosted Robbie in New Jersey his last day.
And she had her running backpack or running vest,
hydration vest.
And then Robbie grabbed it from her.
And then I said, "Hey, Robbie."
Robbie handed it to me and then I went for it.
Yeah.
She was surprised.
Yeah, she had an idea.
And actually I was like-
But how did you hide the ring beforehand,
so she didn't find it for the whole adventure?
I didn't even have the ring with me.
Oh was it in in New Jersey
you had a friend get it or something?
No, I was trying to figure how I was gonna do this.
And I called my guardian
who came to see me a few days before.
I said, "I was just letting you guys know
I'm gonna propose to the Lex.
And I just want you guys know ahead of time
since I won't see you before."
And then he goes, "Do you have a ring?"
I was like, "No."
He goes, "All right."
He drove to a jeweler and FaceTime me and said,
"Hey, can you pick one?"
I said, "Well, I want it to be unique."
And so, we did a deal with a jeweler
where we can pick the ring now and she doesn't like it
or the fitting is not right, we can go and fix it.
So, just to have a ring.
It was either that,
or I was gonna ask her mom for grandmother's ring,
who had passed if she had one in person.
So, I wanted to ask everybody.
And I didn't even ask the mother yet
till the day before that I'm gonna propose.
I asked her father the morning,
'cause I didn't see him until then.
So, she saw me talking to these people, like close people
and I didn't want her to be like,
"Why is Hellah doing that?"
So, I would take my GoPro and say,
"I wanna interview people."
I interviewed her best friend,
but I told her best friend while I was doing the interview.
And then so for her to even fall for the interview thing,
I called her over, "Now time to interview you now."
So, I interviewed her too.
So, she was like, "Oh, he's just interviewing everybody."
But I was telling people that I'm gonna propose,
so they're there at the finish line.
So, that's how I had to set up.
How long have you guys been together?
Nine years this past June 11th.
It was nine years.
I met her at UMass, in college UMass Emerson.
Oh, it goes way back.
Yeah. Yeah.
Nine years ago.
Wow. Wow.
Yeah, it's incredible.
It flew by too really bad.
That was the fastest nine years.
That was the biggest party finish line
for a run across America that ever was.
I don't even know.
Yeah, and Gymshark really went all out for them
to get that and then getting a permit for the road
for us to get the finish line on.
And it was just really fun.
And it was even more exciting to have Casey Neistat there,
to have Robbie, just everybody that-
How did that come together?
Okay, so Gymshark asked me actually,
"Hellah, who do you want at the start of your run
across the country?"
I said, "Rich Roll, Casey Neistat."
You two-
I didn't know.
Nobody told me.
I'm shocked actually, because they asked me.
They said, "Hellah, is there anybody important
that you really look up to or you want at your start?"
You two were the first in my head immediately.
I had no idea.
I knew Robbie was gonna-
I would've joined you for the beginning.
Yeah, I knew Robbie would have came.
Robbie was, I talked to Robbie.
Robbie, said, "Hellah, I'm there for you as a friend.
I'm gonna be there for you."
So, I knew he was doing his thing.
Eventually, I was gonna meet Robbie somewhere,
even if it's the finish.
So, they asked me and I said you two immediately.
Many times and many meetings, we have Zoom meetings.
And so, I thought-
I think there were emails that came in that I didn't see
or didn't pay attention to.
Now I feel bad.
No, that's all right,
because I'm sitting here now with you. (laughs)
But I've mentioned you two.
And then the same thing
and none of that has happened in the beginning.
I didn't see either of you.
So, but in the finish, as I'm finishing, I was asked again,
"Who do you want at to finish last day?"
Rich Roll and Casey.
And those are some of the people I said.
I definitely didn't know about that.
But I completely forgot about it.
Like to a point, I was just so consumed, just get home.
And then I see Casey the next morning.
I'm like, "Whoa, Casey is actually here?"
But I had no idea he was gonna show up.
So, to me too,
they were just asking me if I can have somebody,
maybe they'll try it.
That was gonna be like high happened in the beginning.
And I knew you guys are busy.
It was just that to me when they asked me,
"Who do you think, if you can pick anybody?"
That's my answer.
It was you two.
Yeah.
Well, I can tell you that when I was watching it
unfold on Instagram, I was like, "Why am I not there?"
I was like, I had huge FOMO.
I was like, I should be there.
Everyone is there.
This looks like so much fun.
I can't-
Maybe I should have tried to reach out to you.
I should have DMed you have him do and say,
"Hey, Rich, can you come out too?"
Well, you're here now.
You're here now.
I feel like you should also go to Mali
and take a victory lap.
They probably started your parade there.
I definitely wanna do that.
I'm thinking like around end of the year,
December I go to Mali.
That would be cool.
Yeah. Yeah.
You could make an amazing video out of that too.
Yeah, I'm looking forward to going back home.
'Cause I haven't been there since 2018.
So, it's been some time.
It would also be cool to a video with Buddy
and track like the money that you raised
and kind of help tell the Soles4Souls story
and maybe see what kind of impact is being made in Mali.
Wow, you just gave me a great idea.
Yeah, man.
Yeah.
You're a content creator now.
Yeah, there you go.
Full time, full stop.
Yeah, that is it.
There's no way back.
There's not turning around.
Just going at it.
Yeah, from now on.
Well, before I let you go,
I think it would be good to kind of pivot a little bit
to talk about have a change and staying motivated.
What you've done is so inspirational.
And I feel like you do such a good job
at communicating these ideas in a relatable way.
So, for the people that are watching or listening
who are feeling inspired
and know they need to get off the couch and do something,
it doesn't necessarily have to be a run streak,
but perhaps, are in the process
of rethinking their relationship to their body
and their selves and the trajectory that they're on in life,
like how do you speak to that person?
I always say, do something that's pressure-free
and do something that's attainable.
Always those are the biggest factor for me.
And pressure-free, meaning, don't do it
because someone else is doing it,
do it because you wanna do it and do it on your own timing.
Don't feel you gotta get it done.
If it's a goal, whatever,
you don't have to get it done in 10 days,
if you need a month, a month is okay.
So, just do it pressure-free.
Because of that, I fell in love with running.
I never thought it was no chance.
And now I get excited to run.
And I know running is tough.
It has it's brutal days,
but like I'm still excited to go at it.
So, do it-
You don't feel the pressure of maintaining the streak.
Nope, zero pressure.
And I always say this too.
This is how I feel about it.
The day that I feel like it becomes more of a pressure
and I'm not liking it, I'm gonna stop.
I'll stop.
And then I don't know when that day is.
Give yourself that permission.
Yeah. Yeah.
And I know I'll find something else.
I'll find something else.
So, making sure it's not,
I don't have to go,
I know I don't have to go run to keep a streak going,
but I just do it because it feels good.
I enjoy it and I wanna keep sharing it.
So, pressure-free, do it something that's attainable.
And just think about even spending five minutes a day
goes a long way.
If it's something you love already,
or you're thinking about, you've been thinking about,
that's the all the sign to start doing it.
So, if that hadn't just been five minutes a day,
it's about volume.
Five minutes a day for seven days a week, it's gonna add up.
But if you just do it today and you take a few days off,
that's not it.
If you can do 10 minutes a day, that's also 10 minutes.
You can at least find out your day
if it's important enough to you.
So, as long as you wanna do it and just pressure-free
and get after it.
And don't think about anybody.
Even don't compare.
Even if it's running, don't compare yourself to these people
who are doing hundreds of miles,
these fast pace or these, whatever.
Everybody has their own process, their own journey.
And if that's the goal, you'll get there,
just one day at a time.
That's it.
I love it, man.
Yeah, one day at a time.
What about somebody who's stuck in a job
that they feel like isn't heading in the right direction?
Like you've done this pivot,
you've reinvented yourself from one career to the next.
How do you think about outside of running or fitness,
making those kinds of pivots?
Yeah, so there's two ways that I think that may work
that kind of worked for me.
So, when I was starting to run streak,
I was actually working 9:00 to 5:00.
And so-
Just like a typical job or something?
A normal job.
I was working at a place called Air Brook.
It was a limousine company.
I was data entry because I used data.
But it was a rental car.
So, I was there literally.
So, training, I started training people
aside soccer, speed and agility and soccer technique.
And I was seeing that that's not guaranteed.
I know the 40 whatever hours a week, money is guaranteed.
But that one if the client canceled,
I knew that week you might not get money.
But what I started looking at during those hours,
I said, you know what,
sometime you do a little bit that you don't wanna do
just to support your dreams,
but making sure you're good with it mentally.
If it's not working for you mentally,
you gotta leave that environment.
So, I literally told myself, this is for now.
And now you see that you're not really,
this is not good for you mentally,
'cause I really didn't like it.
And I said, leap of faith, quit the job,
focus your energy on the soccer training.
And I quit the job.
And that actually, the business literally doubled
after I put my energy into it, when I was scared of it.
So, it's one of those things,
when you're stuck in a bubble right now,
I'd say just the leap of faith.
If you feel like you're stuck in a bubble,
that's telling you everything already.
If you believe in God or the universe,
if you feel like you're stuck,
that's the sign for you to make that move.
And it may be scary.
And when I did that I was very scared
because I'm thinking that training is not guaranteed,
but the 9:00 to 5:00 was guaranteed a weekly money
that I was getting.
But if you take the leap of faith,
that's when you discover other things.
And then when you know, again,
when you get put in an uncomfortable situation,
you'll find a way out.
It might be brutal, whatever.
You'll find that next thing
that's gonna help you sustain the life that you wanna live.
So, just take a leap of faith.
I think that's what it is.
We're afraid to fail.
Be okay to fail because it's not even failing.
It's just a part of just progressing and learning.
So, I don't even see failure as failure anymore.
It's just that, "Oh, now I know what to do better."
I know what not to do.
I hate the word failure.
Yeah, just take that leap of faith.
It's more about having the courage to try.
Yeah, that's exactly it.
And it's the courage.
Actually that's the perfect word.
Because I had to have the courage to say, you know what?
I need to just stop this and go to the training.
And I was running on the side.
And also when something is not working for you,
Belle said this to me, she said to me,
and she said, "Sometime you are really stuck into something.
You want it so bad, it's not working out,
but you have no idea it's preparing you
for something better."
I think that was perfectly for my story.
I wanted soccer so bad.
I kept holding onto it so tight and I didn't wanna let go,
but it was actually preparing me
for what I'm doing right now.
Well, often when you're holding on too tightly,
you're myopic to the greater opportunity.
You can't see it because you're stuck
in a certain kind of pattern.
And there is a mystical power to that idea
of the leap of faith.
Because if you have one foot in one world
and one foot in the next world,
you're signaling to the universe that you're not ready
for whatever the next thing is.
Yeah, exactly, yeah.
Because you're holding on to some illusion of security
that that current situation
or that past idea represents for you.
And it's only in the let going of it,
that you provide the space for the new thing to come in.
And you don't know how capable or resilient you are,
until you are sort of chartering treacherous waters
and your back is up against the wall.
And it's in that being tested
that I think you allow yourself to come into
a greater capacity for potential.
Exactly.
Can you write another book?
That was really good.
(Rich laughs)
That was so, that's literally it.
That's literally perfectly said.
Honestly, that's-
It's hard though, man.
Yeah, and you gotta-
I look at you and I'm like I'm so much older than you.
I'm like, you're so young.
Who cares?
Like take the risk, do it.
You're super young too.
What do you got to lose, man?
You could get back to work at the limousine company.
Yeah, exactly.
Worst-case scenario.
And also, I like too, this thinking mentality.
I used to think, "Oh, plan B."
And I'm like, no, there's no plan B.
There's only plan A for me.
So, plan A means if I'm planning to do something
and it's not working,
it doesn't mean I'm gonna quit to go to...
I'm not reverting to another one.
I'm just gonna reroute.
Because if you have a, let me, this is my fallback now,
now you're kind of like not going all out
for that one thing you want.
You're thinking, "Oh, if it doesn't work,
there's this thing also."
But if you just say, I'm gonna make it work.
If plan A doesn't work, just reroute.
Take a different route.
And even the GPS thing,
I don't know if you've heard of this,
but I've heard this somewhere.
I don't know who has said.
If you're going somewhere, you're on a highway,
you missed the exit, guess what the GPS does?
It doesn't quit on you every routes.
It might take you in the longer direction, but reroutes.
So, if plan A isn't working,
it doesn't mean it's not gonna work.
Just reroute.
There's maybe another loophole that you gotta find
to make it happen.
So, and thinking also worst-case scenario,
you'll find something will come.
You'll survive.
And that's everybody I speak to,
and even reading books, even the likes of yourself,
you can see this thing that you know
that everything that you guys have, did not come overnight.
You worked on it.
How you changed your lifestyle.
But people will see what you're able to do right now
is very amazing, is very all.
But do they realize you had to go through so much,
you have to literally go through all this process
to get to where you're at.
So, we also have to think that.
We see everybody on top of what they're doing right now
and it's amazing, but they had to start somewhere.
So, it's okay if I'm still trying to figure it out
till this day.
Yeah.
In A, they call it, you can't translate something
you haven't got.
Like you have to burn in the fire, right?
You have to emerge from some experience,
whether it be a hardship or whatever,
to carry a certain resonance that magnetizes other people.
So, when I look at you, your story,
what you've accomplished,
I appreciate that it didn't happen overnight.
Thank you. Yeah, me too.
I mean, you've been doing this way 1500 days of running
in a row.
Like you've put in a lot of work.
And you strike me as somebody who's very self-actualized
or integrated.
Like I don't know whether you've been to therapy,
but whatever demons you may or may not have,
like you've dealt with them
and you're able to stand in your strength in a certain way.
Thank you.
And there's something about the positivity
that flows outward from you,
that isn't just a guiding force for yourself.
It's very attractive to other people.
I appreciate that, thank you.
People see that.
A lot of people have run across the country, right?
But there's something about your experience doing it
and the way that you shared it
and the spirit with which you carried yourself
throughout this experience that make people wanna know more.
They wanna know more about you.
And that attracts Casey to your front yard
or all these things that are coming to you.
Thank you.
And that doesn't happen by happenstance.
That happens because you've put in
a tremendous amount of work and very intentional
in the way that you're approaching these things.
And it's very commendable the way that you're-
I appreciate. That means a lot.
I think, I mean, it's cool
that you ran across the country,
it's cool that you've run 1500 days in a row,
but when I look at you,
like I wanna sit down across from you
because I just like your spirit and your soul.
Thank you so much.
That means a lot.
Yeah. Yeah.
Thank you.
And I think there's so much more
that you're gonna be contributing and offering to the world.
I appreciate that.
It's the same thing, I'm like,
wait, I'm coming here to talk to Rich Roll?
And let me tell you, I'm pretty sure you know how big
you've impacted so many people,
especially with plant-based across the world,
but people saw my Strava location,
everybody's like "Rich Roll."
Oh, 'cause you from Strava today.
Yeah, people know.
People are very attentive.
And I'm like, wait, this is some detective stuff.
I didn't say anything.
I didn't mention anything.
And in fact I'm like, "I'm in LA,
I'll let you guys know why I'm here if I can or not."
But not even the people
that are so impacted by what you've done is just incredible.
Even my neighbor, when I told him, his jaw dropped.
He said, "There's no way."
He said, "Dang it."
He said, "Someone borrowed my book.
I wanna give it to you so he can sign it and bring it back."
He was telling me all this stuff,
because they have changed their lifestyle.
They're going plant-based because of you.
They are seeing what they're able to do.
And they're seeing that it's not too late.
And that all comes from what you've done
and showing and prove it to people
that you could do amazing things
with what you're putting in your body
and push yourself as a runner on top of that.
So, thank you.
I appreciate that, man, as well.
Because we're just here, we do our thing.
It's like I know there's people listening and watching
and stuff like that,
but it means something to me that you would say that.
So, much love to those people.
Yeah, and those are all factual.
It's just that you see it all over.
Yeah.
So, I'm very excited to let people know
I'm in this presence 'cause this is incredible.
Thank you.
What beyond Leadville is on the road?
Like what are you thinking about in terms of that?
Yes. I definitely wanna run in every continent.
I don't know when or how I'm gonna make it happen.
Continent or country?
Continent?
Every continent right now.
And maybe the countries after that.
'Cause I've been in the North American continent
for most of the majority of the time in the United States.
But if I can run in every continent,
which that means to run a marathon in every continent,
which if it means to meet the hellagood family members,
the people have been supportive and just run with them,
I think that'd be pretty cool.
That's cool.
And just, and then I wanna do 100-mile race.
I said not just to go run a 100 miles with myself,
just to be actually in the high altitude.
Because I can go run a 100 miles in the air I'm at,
but I wanna actually Leadville, when I-
Yeah, there's altitude and then there's Leadville.
Exactly.
That's a totally different thing.
So, when I wanna do Leadville,
I wanna dedicate my energy now
into being trained well for it.
I don't wanna just show up, "Oh, I run every day.
Let me go do now."
It doesn't work like that.
So, I wanna like take time off and maybe live in that area
for a couple months just to get my body ready
and training around that area at that altitude
and then be ready for the race.
So, maybe we're looking at 2022.
Yeah.
Yeah, 'cause my legs are,
the pace I've been running out, I can go 20, 30, 40 miles.
But when I try to pick up the pace
to a certain pace that I wanna just cruise in,
it feels like there's like brick ties to both legs.
It won't pick up.
Well, your training has acclimated you
to maintain a certain pace for an extended period of time,
but you never extend yourself past that aerobic threshold.
So, you have no anaerobic power at all, right?
For that, yeah.
It goes from like 140 beats a minute
at like seven-minute pace or whatever it is.
But then you go just a little bit over that,
you quickly fall apart.
Yeah, I completely fall apart.
(Rich laughs)
So, but I can't wait to get that strength back.
And I'm kinda like in between where like, man, the ultra,
I have so much like fascination about ultra runners
and what they do.
It's a complete different part of running
that I really didn't understand
till I did the transcontinental.
And now I'm like, do I wanna just be a long distance runner,
or I wanna be ultra runner?
I was like, I wanna run ultras.
I wanna-
Well, you are an ultra runner.
You know that, right?
Yes, that is true
You just ran across America.
This idea that you're not an ultra runner is preposterous.
Thank you.
It makes you, I guess, do more ultra running
and instead of like coming back to just my regular running,
like I wanna do more ultra distance.
I wanna do races that are just,
but I wanna have a reason behind it for me.
And there's a reason behind it.
I wanna dig harder because I don't wanna do it for myself
because I love what I'm doing.
But also if I wanna get uncomfortable
with the uncomfortable,
I wanna have a reason to hold on no matter what,
no matter the circumstances.
Are you gonna keep doing it with Soles4Souls?
I think I'm gonna keep doing.
Yeah, and then my goal actually truly
is to be able to just help any nonprofit.
And Soles4Souls was my number one.
And if I can keep helping whatever I do
and that goes to them or anywhere else,
I will probably do it.
You've done some stuff for charity: water too.
Yeah, that was really,
the cool story about that is I just put it on YouTube.
I said, my goal in life is to just do things for non-profit
and just help because a lot of people have helped me
in my life.
I've had so many helping hands and I wanna give back.
And charity: water saw that YouTube video
and they reached out.
And they said, "In fact, this campaign we're doing
is for Mali, your country."
And guess what?
It was the village where my mom grew up.
Get out.
Yeah.
It literally worked out perfectly.
And that's the village we were left in '97
with my mom's sister where she passed away.
So, I lived there.
And they say, we're trying to get water-
And there was no water there.
Trying to get water to 25,000.
I called, "Mom, guess what?
Guess what?
I'm trying to raise money to give 25,000 people clean water
in Sikasso, which is a region in Mali.
It's one of the regions.
And that's where you grew up.
And literally her hometown.
And I was like, I'm all for it.
And it was really cool to be able
to be part of something special to help people get water,
but it kinda really, it really did hit home.
It was like my mom's home.
Have they built that well yet?
I don't know if they have 'cause COVID was happening,
but I wanna be there.
You're a content creator, I don't want to tell you this,
but you need to go to Mali and film.
If they haven't built it yet,
you need there when they unveil it.
Yeah.
But we ended up doing enough
to give more than 25,000 people clean water.
And then my community raised a lot of money.
My goal is just to raise $1000.
We raised so much more than that.
That's cool.
And I couldn't believe this.
So, I thank all the supporters
for donating to that cause,
which that was my first biggest.
Have you met Scott Harrison?
No.
He's the founder.
I haven't met him, yeah.
You gotta meet.
Yeah, I saw his stories and what he did,
how he has changed his lifestyle too.
It's unbelievable.
It's super inspirational.
Yeah, it really is.
And it makes you think that whenever we think it's too late,
right now we can change everything.
You just gotta stop and spot check.
His course correct is crazy.
Yeah.
And this wild partying.
And all of that, what he used to do.
To becoming this unbelievable public servant.
And just not just creating this incredible nonprofit,
but really reinventing and re-imagining
what giving looks like by making it aspirational
with a brand of charity: water, is just cool.
It's awesome what they do.
Yeah, awesome too for people to have clean water.
Like they also-
And the impact is unbelievable.
Yeah, and they literally get water,
having a well for forever.
Yeah, it's just 'cause Mali,
there's certain areas that still don't have water.
And then I tell my dad, of course my dad's like,
"Hellah, can you do my village too?"
I said, "Dad, I thought you didn't want me to run.
I'm using running to bring awareness to places."
That was the joke.
I was joking with him.
Yeah.
You build a well in the village. (laughs)
Yeah. (laughs) Yeah.
That must just blow his mind.
Yeah, he was like, "What?"
And he said, "You did that for moms village?"
I said it wasn't only me.
It took a whole crowd of my followers to donate.
It's a different village.
Yeah, it took a village to build another village.
And he couldn't believe it.
So, he was like reading the articles and stuff like that.
Wow, that's cool.
Yeah, that was a proud moment to be able to do that.
And I'll say all comes down to, again,
an ability that not everyone has, is to run.
So, I'm glad I could use my ability,
and having an audience that could participate
in something like that.
And anybody can say in my life,
I've helped to a cause, the people who don't know.
You changed someone's life that you don't even know,
you'll never meet or hear of,
but you've changed their life forever.
So, and wedding that thing that you love to service
in a meaningful way is the real differentiator.
There's nothing like it.
That gives your own life such depth.
Yeah, and purpose.
And purpose.
Yeah, and a purpose too, I always tell people,
don't think that if you're not a big celebrity,
you don't have a major platform,
that you don't have a purpose.
I think we're all here for a reason.
We all have a purpose.
And your purpose could even be
just saying something nice to someone
and you have no idea what they were dealing with.
And they go home, they change their whole outlook
or their whole energy and life.
And you just saved their life.
And you have no idea that you fulfill your purpose.
So, just because you're not on tabloids,
or you're not on social media with big followings,
or you're not getting articles written about you,
does not mean you don't have a purpose.
We're all here for a reason.
And we just have to keep doing what we love
and then you're fulfilling your purpose
without even knowing.
So, yeah.
Yeah, I believe that.
I can't remember who said it,
but somebody said your job,
there's two parts of your life.
The first part of your life
is trying to figure out what that purpose is,
and the second part is fulfilling that purpose
or doing that thing.
Yeah.
And you're doing it, man.
Thank you. Thank you
And it's only just begun.
Yeah, I'm excited for the future.
You're a young man with a bright future.
Thank you.
I love you.
I'm here to support you in any way I can.
Likewise. Thank you so much.
I love everything that you're doing.
I'm just delighted that you took the time to come.
Thank you for having me.
There's no doubt about it that I was not gonna be here
when I heard it.
Thank you so much.
You're very welcome.
If you wanna hook up with Hellah,
best place to do that is online on his YouTube channel,
hellagood.
Yeah, hellagood on YouTube, hellagood9 on Instagram
and same thing on Twitter.
I'm not very active on Twitter, but yeah, those platforms.
I'm most active on Instagram and YouTube.
Yeah.
Hellagood9.
Yeah, hellagood9 on Instagram.
And are you still raising money for Soles4Souls?
Yeah, I'm still raising money for Soles4Souls
and collecting shoes.
And I feel like it's something
that I don't even have to stop.
I could just keep going wherever I can.
Of course, right?
Yeah, 'cause.
So, I'll link up in the show notes,
all of those accounts, of course,
but also the link for people who wanna contribute
to Soles4Souls and also the charity: water tank as well.
Yeah. Yeah.
Which would be cool.
Yes.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
Yeah. All right, man.
Come and talk to me again sometime.
Definitely will.
I'm coming out to New York soon too.
Will you come into the city and run with it me?
Let me know.
I'm there.
I'm literally like minutes away from New York City.
As long as you let me know, I'm coming over.
Definitely will, man.
Yes, thank you so much.
All right, appreciate you, brother.
Peace.
Thank you.
Plants.
(upbeat music)